and we'll be joining us shortly we had
another meeting earlier with the state
house
uh before we um
before we go very far i'll
give i have a clip that
needs to be read every morning
quality is important for members to
speak clearly with some volume soft
voices may be heard they're hard to
understand
microphones and movement may not sound
very well be careful about side
conversations
uh and then also the points pointed out
[Music]
also
the sign-in sheet will stop accepting
new instances for those who wish to
speak at 8 a.m the day of the
committee's hearing if you sign in after
that time the committee will not have
your name before them however the chair
will provide an opportunity for you to
speak after all extra names are followed
at that time raise your hand be
recognized the science chief will follow
the purpose of registering your opinion
at 11 59 pm today
as chair or acting chairman of this
committee the house election law
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency replay by the governor as a
result of the total 19 pandemic and in
accordance with public schools 67 and
the government's immigrant supporter
number 12.
pursuant to executive orders 2020-04
public body is authorized to be
electronic
the public hearing on bills refer to the
committee and schedule the house
calendar for today
executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee
and selects legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting
with the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary to participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform on our telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar through the electronic calendar
on the general court website
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-2600
or email hcs lag.state.nh.us
the event the public is unable to access
the meeting meeting will be apparent in
these kids
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll powell vote
by taking your old call attendance when
each member states their presence please
also state whether there is anyone in
the boom of you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
and with that i will begin the wall
again chairman griffin will be
joining us shortly
mcdonald lying president
representative o'brien
president
representative sweeney president
representative haywood
here
representative barry here
representative growing here
representative
here
representative wells here
representative cody here
in nashua alone
thank you
representative ward
here in portsmouth one family member in
the house
representative
i am present um uh at my home in nashua
and there is nobody here in the room
with me at the present time
representative
um
present uh in my home office by myself
thank you
representative
i'm here in manchester
and there's just one other family member
in the house
[Music]
sorry i couldn't unmute myself i'm
present
alone in my home office in concord
representative
here and i'm at home alone
[Music]
hi i'm here in my home in portsmouth and
there's another family member in the
house
representative
president alone in hanover new hampshire
all members are present except again
chairman griffin will be joining us
shortly so philly we're going to be
flawed
and as has been our custom i would ask
you to join me with me
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you
okay i believe i've done all of the
preliminaries
and that will get to the first bill
which is a house bill of 480.
we have four people signing up to speak
the
first one is a deborah sumner from
gathering
and let me see if i can
bring you in um
[Applause]
[Music]
mr chairman uh representative edwards
has his hand up in the uh audience as
the
sponsor i believe sorry i'm sorry um
yes the sponsor should speak but i
apologize
okay you're you're ahead of the game
with um deborah sumner being in you're
upgraded uh promoted him
i have not i i would be happy to if
you'd like me to love you don't mind
that'd be great
representative edward please go ahead
and i apologize
uh thank you mr chairman uh and members
of the election committee i'm i'm
representative jess edwards representing
auburn chester and sandown and i can't
blame you uh mr chair because uh miss
deborah sumner
is the brains of this operation
uh for for those of you who have been
following uh election law uh apparently
this is the fourth time a bill similar
to this has been submitted
um and ms sumner has been the
um
the the leading
uh citizen activist uh pushing it
i think um
that would trigger the question well you
know four times in a row what's changed
and what i think
has changed and why this bill
takes on a new light and should be
looked at differently than perhaps it
has been historically
is that
in this past november election
in states
not new hampshire but
um there was reason for
local populations in particular cities
within states
to become this is very suspicious of the
process
uh pole uh watchers
had been pushed way out of a normal
distance and
and were denied an ability to oversee
the counting of the of the ballots and
the whole process of introducing ballots
to the count
and
so in many
cities across the country
there is a a
great concern
that
the ballots
weren't treated properly and
and so what this bill would do
would be to give new hampshire residents
the assurance
that there is a method
for
local citizens to
get involved in
looking at the counts
after the fact after the recounts
but to take a look at the ballots uh by
making the cast ballots
part of what is discoverable under 91a
uh right now the cast ballots are are
hidden from view from the public and are
not able to be seen
other than in a recount situation
and um and and as we're
witnessing
um that's probably not a sufficient
amount of transparency
to adapt
to a wide range of potential situations
in which the public interest in the cast
ballots are is particularly keen
so what this bill
is wanting to do
is to shine sunlight
on the election process
and i think in doing so
the first thing that would happen would
be that the public would become more
confident in the results
knowing that they could check
the mechanics and the in the counts
themselves
so so public trust would be enhanced and
i think public trust is essential to
acceptance of being governed
and is
useful to just maintaining domestic
tranquility
the other thing that could happen
is if there was ever a situation in
which
somebody had a poll
wished to do something nefarious
they would know that they probably ought
not to do it because there's a
possibility
that would be introduced with this bill
there's a possibility that they could be
caught
other than
if an if a candidate requested a recount
and so it's always good to just keep
people honest
knowing that there may be a way to to
check up on them
so um this bill i think has been opposed
historically by the secretary of state's
office i've not talked to um the
secretary or state or uh
or
his deputy mr scanlon about the bill
um i understand from the sumner that
there have been three
issues um that the secretary of state uh
is concerned about one of them being
privacy
and i i think
that there ought to be a way
to uh deal with the secretary of state's
issues
in an amendment so
um so i i would hope that the the
committee would look favorably on 480
and because it's such a
nice cornerstone to
public trust and the fidelity of our
elections i i would hope that the
concept would be
appreciated
in and if we were uh if this bill were
to be retained so that we could work out
details with the secretary of state i i
would i would love to work with my
friend mr scanlon and my new friend ms
sumner to to figure out uh how to
uh
you know round the square
so
with that uh i'll take questions if
there are any i'll probably end up
deferring to ms sumner though
okay
questions for representative edwards
so people in here meanwhile or online
representative ward
thank you mr chair thank you
representative edwards for taking my
question
you mentioned a number of cities where
you
mentioned irregularities in a viewing in
viewing the
ballots and so forth could you provide
your source and cite a few specific
examples where that happened
i i certainly can um
but i i think it's a
common public knowledge that's out in
the public domain
that we've seen videos of
people
at the polls
um
segregating poll watchers
putting them behind lines where
they that were not typical for that
polling site and and and rendering them
unable to uh participate as a poll
watcher and so
i i i won't be providing examples
because i don't want to create
a controversy over trump
this is not about trump this is about
new hampshire
and making sure that we anticipate
potential problems
and
provide for a safety valve
should those problems ever occur here
and follow up mr chair
yes okay
just
be very helpful to the committee i think
if you could cite where you saw these
videos
can you do that
you know i don't think i will and and
the reason i don't think i will is
because i think it just opens up a level
of distraction
um and and i think we just should stay
focused
on uh the potential or the or the value
that we can see implicitly
in allowing public transparency we have
91a for a reason it's because the state
has a strong belief in
corporate access to records and
transparencies and the in the vast range
of benefits that are brought about by
uh having transparency in our governing
processes and so we're we're taking a
very well understood aspect of new
hampshire's culture
and
injecting it a little deeper into the
way in which we conduct our elections
and i i think i think uh that ought to
be sufficient
thank you
thank you so representative bergeron
oh well remember how i can do it for us
sorry oh thank thank you i i that either
way it's fine thank you so much mr chair
and um thank you representative edwards
for taking my question too i
just wanted to um
revisit that statement i think i heard
you say which is that this bill is
trying to solve problems that exist in
other parts of the country but that
don't exist in new hampshire is did i
hear that correctly
you could you could have heard what i
said and interpreted it in that way
that's a that's not a bad interpretation
but so i appreciate the question and the
opportunity to clarify
and let's let's bring this home a little
bit
we know
that there's great public concern
about the votes in windham in november
we know this
because we pay attention to the media
and we know that the senate thought it
was so important that they passed a bill
24 to nothing to take a deeper look at
what it what what on and window
now why do we know that there was even a
problem in wyndham we know because
it happened
that the erroneous vote vote tallies
were so close that one of the
candidates requested a recount
had a recount not been requested or not
been appropriate
the
obvious
issues in windham would not have been
exposed to the public
um i know that there were people
in windham who've been watching uh the
results of their elections for years and
years who
that night of the election when they saw
the results they believed something was
wrong
there not been a recount they never
would have gotten satisfaction to their
question so this opens up
again a safety valve
to just make sure that our citizens have
an opportunity to verify
results
and you know there's a saying you know
trust but verify
i i think in new hampshire we're able to
lend our election officials across the
state a great deal of trust
but there are those situations where
the verification
process potential
is is would be beneficial i hope that
answers your question sir
thank you very much sir yes
uh thank you mr chairman representative
edwards said a couple quick questions if
i may
um
supposing some individuals came in to
examine the ballots and they did their
own
count of ballots cast for a race or
multiple races
in a ward i come from nashua
and they come up with a number that's
different
than what was reported on the official
return of votes form
there's no saying it's accurate
but what happens if then these folks
go to the press and say well we found a
different number
than was recorded with the secretary of
state
the information's out there the claim is
out there but what happens next
well so
that's a great question really a great
question and and it could be really uh
stimulative
of of some discussion around a potential
amendment to this bill and speaks to
why retaining it might be the right
um but
um the in the first instance even before
we get to to
to the heart of your question
is
if there really is
has been a problem
is society benefited by ignorance
if there was a problem but nobody is
aware of it are we better off than we
would be if we knew there was a problem
or thought there was a problem and it
gave us something actionable to look at
and i would say
that i am
anti-ignorance
i am pro
information
and if they do the count we have
additional relevant important
information
what we do with that information
i think would depend on
a number of factors that get into a
bunch of hypotheticals that i i don't
know if i can address on the fly
but if uh it's a credible enough set of
information to where it appears as
though
um you know
serious errors or or crime occurred then
i imagine the ag office could step in at
that point and conduct a separate
investigation
but
i i prefer sunlight i i prefer
information over ignorance and i think
we could figure out what to do
with that information
either prospectively as we look at this
bill or
maybe in the years to come as we have
some experience with
it for the question mr chairman
okay and and this is my last question
um
the bill says that towns and cities may
request reimbursement of additional
expenses i'm not quite sure what
additional expenses means but
i would estimate in nashua for
individuals to come into city hall
examine
ballots for four hours for whatever
purpose
the city clerk would probably have to
have three people on staff to
assist them and monitor their behavior
uh so the cost could prob and and the
ballot boxes would have to be retrieved
and returned from off-site storage
um i would expect that the cost would be
about five hundred dollars for a
four-hour uh block of time
uh
and and this can be done multiple times
for the same ballots by different people
over the course of 22 months in the case
of a federal election
so who's going to pay for it
should it be the people requesting
access to the ballot should it be the
towns and cities should it be the
secretary of state
you know i'm i'm not exactly sure what's
in uh what 480 says to that particular
question of who pays i think it cites
um
some fund
that's at the state level that i haven't
double checked to make sure that that is
a funded line and how much money is in
there
uh i i would think that if i were
sitting down and working it out with you
i would i would want
um the people requesting the survey uh
or the the review of the ballots to to
have a substantial if not 100
uh requirement to pay for the
incremental costs
and i would want some assurance that the
costs uh were indeed fair
and incremental and and not intended to
be so high
that nobody ever challenged it so
there's there
you'd have to walk i think a line there
to
protect the taxpayer and also protect
the right of the public for access
okay thank you representative edwards
thank you
anyone else any other committee members
wish to ask representative edwards a
question on this
when you're in the committee room anyone
online
seeing john i guess we're all set
representative thank you very much yes
sir thank you uh and thank you to the
committee thank you
and uh to nominate a seminar uh if you'd
like to testify i'd already upgraded you
if you want to run you you may proceed
all right can you hear me
yes okay
um
yes um deborah sumner and um i would say
that in
tries we have actually made some
progress
and i think if representative cody
remembers my first try
i
i spoke way too long and he was very um
very polite and finally wrapping me up
so i've learned to read most of my
testimony from from then on
so if you have copies of my testimony
what i'll try to do is skip through and
try to um
representative edwards did a wonderful
job i i would like to hire him
to do my presentations next year thank
you very much representative edwards
that was very impressive i think you
know a lot more than you think you do
about this subject
okay so i'll skip my introduction and i
would just say um i've been to state
court twice to ask to review ballots in
my town for november 2010
and november 2012
if i'd been able to raise 10 to 15 000
to pay an attorney i would have asked to
review ballots for one questionable
contest in november 2016.
okay yes election transparency
representative edwards already dealt
with that election transparency equals
trust in elections trusting government
so we say we believe in transparency but
what does that actually mean when we
look at ballots that are counted inside
a computer
instead of required to be voted to be
founded in public as our constitution
and law is required
so i hope the legislature will expect
and direct the secretary of state to
shift from his
power over style of winning at any cost
to one of power with emphasis in
cooperation problem solving with local
communities and citizens
the likely result would be better use of
all of our time energy and money and
elections we voters have reason to trust
and be proud of
developing mutual trust and respect
between citizens and our government
needs work on both sides and we
acknowledge that
if you directed mr scanlon to work with
me and representative edwards on
specific language i believe we can
easily resolve the three remaining
concerns
from hb 1390 which was sent to study
committee last year
uh vote buying intimidation schemes
security of voted ballots
good policy question mark
so i'll skip through one and two you can
read that i think those are really
non-issues that are resolvable with
just compliance with current law
so number three
mr scanlon believes hiding evidence of
problems in our elections including the
possibility fraud occurred is good
policy
i strongly disagree and i find no basis
for that position in our constitution
laws are what defines good policy
in states where ballots are public
records
citizens have found problems and can
make recommendations to policymakers of
how to fix them
elections belong to the public
without information we can't do our job
as citizens
our right to know is our right to truth
and a protected protected free speech
right
policy makers are deprived of accurate
information to make good public policy
and this is something that i think is um
common to people who are involved with
right to know issues we are seen as the
enemy of government we citizens are
often seen as the enemy that we are
troublemakers instead of starting to
work in partnership to make things
better for all of us to start having
more of a cooperative instead of an
adversarial relationship so this is not
unique to this particular situation this
is an issue we are trying to deal with
throughout the with right to know
throughout the state
so
examples of
how um citizens how we can do better
make get use information cooperatively
and make better choices
we know that dust in the scanner can
cause false overvote readings because in
wisconsin where ballots and images are
public records citizens investigated
that issue
number two specific to new hampshire the
sos mag successfully argued against the
court granting the access to november
2012 jaffrey ballots that showed a 2.5
over voted ballot rate if i had been
able to look at ballots i knew if two
fraud possibilities at that time i know
of four now
i might have
i might have found no evidence of fraud
but that voter intent on 68 of the 71
ballot showed they contained legal votes
that would have been counted in a hand
count town or recount i could have come
to you sooner than 2018 and maybe that
problem could have been corrected
earlier
in his recent testimony on
sb-79 mr scanlon acknowledged two to two
to three percent of votes not counted by
the scanner
are legal votes
and hb 491 which will be your next
hearing will attempt to correct that
problem
the attorney general has been asked to
investigate specific issues in windham
and derry from november 2020 election
but seems to be confused about his
statutory authority to do so
citizens and local citizens
should be able to investigate election
questions themselves because elections
are under public local control and the
responsibility of each community
and we'll talk more about the overvote
situation
in dairy in the next hearing
these two links regarding the 2010
governor's race in bridgeport
connecticut showed how bridgeport
officials the media and citizens work
together to investigate and recommend
improvements including better training
more time for officials to determine and
report results and election law
enforcement they found no evidence of
intentional errors
okay the better idea which i've
mentioned to our representative edwards
but we decided to just bring it to your
attention and we'll see what you think
um this is
an idea from a house judiciary committee
member um
he suggested it it adds two lines to rsa
91 a five
dealing with the exemptions
ballot shall not be available for public
inspection until after the recount
period or any legal challenge to an
election has ended
the records custodian may request that
the attorney general or secretary of
state personnel supervise the review
that would allow local officials the
option of asking for the attorney
general or super sos to supervise the
review that will address both one and
two of the secretary of state's concerns
and allow very busy town city clerks to
attend to their other important duties
rsa already deals with exemptions for
legitimate privacy reasons towns and
cities have processes in place to deal
with public records requests and there's
no question that our right to know is a
burden for public officials again i'm a
former reporter so i know it from that
perspective as well
but our job is citizens
and
our job
as citizens and government is to
continually work to make this less
burdensome
and with electronic records um that's
becoming more and more possible
uh unfortunately
without
the light shining things can happen that
shouldn't we are an essential check and
balance in keeping uh government open
and accountable even though we can be a
pain at times and we acknowledge that
and we can try to do better on that too
i've included information from last
year's testimony at the end and i'll
just skip to the very last paragraph on
page four
about why
ballots were exempted in new hampshire
after the march 2016 supreme opinion in
my case i found evidence of why dave
scanlon and bud fitch
wanted ballots removed from rsa 91a in
legislative history for another 2003
however required bill h.b 577.
they said a superior court had granted
the petitioner access to ballots because
they hadn't been exempted that was the
reason
the senate sponsor of the non-german
amendment to h.b 627 misled the senate
saying it was needed to comply with
federal law
probably most legislators and no one in
the public were aware it had been added
after the public hearing on the bill so
there was no specific reason
um for re-exempting them in the first
place all right so it was right to know
if anybody has
some experience with that you need to
have a good reason to exempt
a record you can't just do it because
it's inconvenient
or it might cause some embarrassment if
someone found something that some
official didn't want them to find all
right so this that there has to be a
good reason if you're going to exempt
something any any it public records
um
so
i think um
i've added a link that summarizes how
other states are dealing with ballots
and images as public records
um and in some states by the way there
they are traceable to
to voters because there are bar codes
that are added to ballots to keep track
of the ballots
and especially on mailing
ballots so that could be a privacy
reason
that's being contested because it should
there should not be any way to trace any
ballot to a voter we don't have to have
that problem in new hampshire but that
is why some states specifically like
washington state has exempted ballots
from public records because they are
traceable to voters because of the
the bar codes on the on the ballots
um all right so if you care about public
trust in our elections and in government
i know we can make this work
so um is there any questions
thank you mr any questions and committee
members here in the world
any questions from our members of
participating remote
could i just add one more um
response to our representative
bergeron's question earlier in terms of
what happens if you find a different
number
um that happens at times okay the the
ballots that are public records
sometimes they will find discrepancies
um you know again what you would hope
people would do with that information is
then go to your officials see if you can
figure out why there was a discrepancy
and remember the ballots are your facts
okay i mean two different people count
the same ballots and get different
numbers okay that can happen a few all
right you could be off by a few but if
you're finding a significant discrepancy
in that count you would hope people
would go to your people like what
they've tried to do in wyndham to figure
out what happened there it's like what
we would like to find out with in derry
in terms of those overvoted ballots why
are were there so many and can we do
something to prevent it from happening
again we're not going to try to contest
an election
and the only way you can overturn an
election by the way is if there is
evidence of fraud and if there is
evidence of fraud i'm not going to be
able to bring that case it would be the
party of the person who feels that they
are affected by that
discovery that would then take action on
that we have processes in place to deal
with each of these questions and what we
need to do is see are we really going to
have a problem with opening up ballots
as public records in new hampshire i
mean vermont doesn't have a problem they
have one person a year
that's looking
asking to look at balance for research
purposes
um it doesn't have to be a problem all
right and what we need to do is find
cooperative ways of working together to
make it something that's positive as
opposed to negative
thank you miss sumner i think you've
covered that subject matter very well
and
we definitely appreciate your testimony
thank you
uh next uh signed up to speak and i see
she has already been upgraded to a
panelist
hi thank you uh honorable committee
members um i'm honored to be here my
name is carla garrick
and i'm the former state senate
candidate in district 20. i live in
manchester i'm an author and attorney
and i serve on several non-profit boards
including right to know new hampshire
which is a partisan nonpartisan citizens
coalition that works to improve
government transparency a crucial
component of maintaining
public trust in our institutions
right to know new hampshire supports
this bill and i think there's someone
else uh signed up to testify on the
organization's behalf so i'm testifying
today in my personal capacity as a voter
a political candidate and a reformer
i'll also submit this testimony in
written form to the committee via email
afterwards and i asked that it formed
part of the permanent record for this
bill
i ask you to today support house bill
480 in order to ensure the utmost
transparency in election process by
allowing ballots to become part of the
public record subject to our wonderful
9180 and open to inspection by
interested parties and available to
anyone who wishes to set their minds at
ease
election integrity is a crucial part of
a functioning government
more transparency leads to more
accountability which in turn instills
trust without transparency and
accountability granite staters will lose
the last vestiges of trust in the system
the new hampshire constitution says our
government shall be open accessible
transparent and responsive
to the people
in 1977 the legislature added a preamble
to that statement saying
openness and the conduct of public
business is essential to a democratic
society the purpose of this chapter
that's 91.8 is to ensure both the
greatest possible public access to the
actions discussions and records of all
public bodies and their accountability
to the people
house bill 480 increases accountability
by increasing checks and balances
in night uh in 2018 i was the republican
candidate for state senate in district
20. during the primary the libertarian
party launched a writing campaign
meaning if i got 30 write-ins i would
appear as a fusion candidate on both the
republican and libertarian
as the you know republican libertarian
candidate on the election ballot
district 20 has six wards and i picked
up about 20 something write-ins in five
of the wards but i only got one write-in
in board 11 which is my home ward and i
know a lot of voters there and i knew
people were writing me it so it was
clear to me
that when ward 11's results came in
something was horribly a mess
i filed for a recount and yes something
was a miss the moderators somehow failed
to record any of the write-ins correctly
and i did in fact receive enough votes
to qualify as a fusion candidate
my question was why were there write-in
votes that were recorded incorrectly i'm
sure it was as everyone else says a
mistake or an oversight or something
went wrong and fortunately the checks
and balances that we had in place
because of the recount did mean that we
caught the problem
but why did the system fail in the first
place why was the original tally wrong
and how often does this happen and where
does it happen
everyone on this committee
is aware of the current investigation of
the wyndham incident where more than 300
votes for were found for each of three
republican candidates during a recount
much like in my case this raises more
questions than it answers
house bill 480 will help address these
sorts of troubling scenarios by allowing
follow-up audits by ordinary concerned
citizens by our granite staters who are
registered voters and this will help us
have the most unimpeachable and solid
election process
this would help us to identify say if
there's an isolated polling station
where there's a problem or maybe there
is you know some kind of repeat offender
and part of this goal of this bill is to
ensure the accuracy of the vote count
and to evaluate the performance of
election officials in other words it's a
check and balance on the check and
balance that the recount already gives
us it gives us that opportunity to see
if there's weird and strange stuff
happening it seems like this seems to be
happening more and more so i think the
time is now to try and pass this bill
obviously increasing transparency serves
to increase
accountability and trust so let's
empower our citizens let's empower our
granite staters to exercise their own
audits to ensure that that trust remains
um i want to address one question that
came up from the gentleman from nashua
um and sort of something that deborah
summers said as well
uh regarding this this notion i think
you know there's this this idea now that
people who want government to be open
and transparent are troublemakers and i
think we do need to move beyond that i
know certainly in nashua there is a sort
of conflict that's going on right now uh
which i think you know leads to that
idea of this has to be so expensive i
think that if we work with municipal we
can actually you know if we just pivot
the way people look at this instead of
saying it's this head-to-head thing but
rather hey guys we're all in the same
boat let's see if we can you know get
the real information to get the real
answer but to the question of costs
maybe one thing the committee could
consider
is um to say
to build in some kind of incentive
structure so basically if there is a
discrepancy
in the vote count then the state must
pay
but if there is no discrepancy found
maybe there's a flat fee that the
citizen group or the citizen must pay
this might be a way that you would both
uh sort of counteract just willy-nilly
you know people just going in and filing
these audits for no apparent reason so
it would create the right incentive
structure so that people
uh you know would have to really think
about does you know is there a reason
why we would do this audit in this case
um so that's pretty much where i'm at i
ask you to please support house bill 480
to increase the election transparency
accountability and trust i thank you for
your time and i'm happy to take
questions
questions from ms garrett from committee
members here in the room
uh representative clara
thank you uh thank you carl i feel like
i can call you carlos since i know each
other um
a lot of them mentioned recently about
the price of this
what do you think is the price of people
not having faith in our elections
i mean it's priceless or
you know integrity in our government
systems is is what you know greases the
wheels and makes everything work so i i
don't think we can put a price on this
thank you any other questions from the
committee members here in the world
any questions from members participating
seeing none
thank you ms garrett for your testimony
thank you
our next sign up to speak is alvin c
i see you've been promoted to catalyst
mr c if you'd like to unmute yourself
probably
testimony
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
um
i just uh my name is alvin c i live in
loudoun and i am strong supporter of the
right to know
for public inspection of the ballots
i think this also allows for
uh
inspection or um
checking the account
for
races that uh people chose not to
uh
the candidate chose not to have a
recount maybe he was
a bit too far and would have been
expensive or something like that but
if somebody wanted to do that or
look at several districts of a statewide
race or something like that just to
uh
get a feel for whether it was
everything was all in the up and up i i
see no compelling reason to hide ballots
from the
public
so i think this should uh pass
and uh
one uh thing uh miss garrick was
talking about uh
write-ins i happen to have looked at
writing
summaries for the town album
for the past several elections
and the clerk had
written up a list of names of the people
who were written in for the various
offices
but those names and the numbers of those
votes
did not
agree with the
number of write-ins that showed up on
the tally on the accuvope machine
i asked about that and
she told me that
several of those were
crude comments and other things like
that so she didn't bother writing them
down
but
in particular in the
primary this past year
there was a specific
campaign for a republican candidate for
registered deeds
and
in that my town report did not report
that person even though
we had known of about 20 people going
into the polls that they had written
that person in
and
even after asking about it
um that was never corrected
so
again thank you for letting me testify
and uh if there are any questions i'll
be glad to answer
thank you mr c any questions to mr c
from
members here in the room
any questions from members participating
remotely
i am seeing none now thank you mr c for
your testimony
uh next sign up to speak is uh spencer
fortier
what do you have been uh promoted to
panelists and do you wanna meet yourself
we'll
give you a testimony
hello mr chairman in honorable committee
members my name is spencer fortier and
i'm a resident of berlin new hampshire
every republican was shorted votes in
windham on election night by nearly 300
votes each
well christie laureate received 99 votes
more than than the votes that were
casted her margin of loss went from
point zero zero five percent to nine
point six percent this is the largest
unexplained voter discrepancy in new
hampshire history
with hb 480 i believe new hampshire will
be moving in the proper direction
election integrity is the most pressing
press most pressing issue to we the
people
without free and fair elections there is
no republic
this isn't a state issue it's an
american issue
the right to vote used to mean something
it used to be the most patriotic act you
could commit
but now that trust in the election
process has faded
and we must turn it back if we want
a way forward a way to unite us patriots
we must pass hb 40
and therefore giving a little power back
to the new hampshire citizenry
we the people must be able to trust our
elections
as soon as that's gone our union will
cease to exist
thank you for your time
and god bless thank you rep edwards and
rep
o'hara for sponsoring this outstanding
bill
uh thank you for your time and i'm
willing to answer any questions the
committee might have for me
thank you mr supporter uh any questions
for mr porter
many members here in the room i'm team
john i'm not
participating remotely
let's see no thank you mr porter very
much
welcome god bless
looking at the attendees uh
three hands up
audrey reporter uh let me promote you
the panelist
so you may
testify
yeah i've got it thank you um excuse me
mr chair i'm here to introduce the next
bill not to speak on this one thank you
okay i'm sorry
okay
is
thank you mr chairman uh and members of
the committee i'm david scanlon deputy
secretary of state
appearing today in opposition to house
bill 480.
um before i make my remarks i will say
that
when miss sumner was giving her comments
uh she did attribute some positions and
statements to me that that i simply
never made and i just want to make that
clear before i move on
there are obviously competing public
interests in in this topic
you know
people
citizens of new hampshire have the right
to know how their government operates
they have the right to see certain
documents
but in the case of elections
it is a different situation
ballots have never been available for
public inspection after an election and
after the recount process has been over
there was
a law that passed a few years ago that
it did make ballots specifically exempt
from the right to know law and that was
because
at the time when the retention period
for holding ballots
was up and and when the ballots would be
to be destroyed
there were some academic requests to
take a look at those ballots to see if
they could determine
certain voting trends in new hampshire
those requests were not honored but to
make it perfectly clear
that ballots were not in a subject
to public inspection
that statute was was created
i disagree with the version that ms
sumner
described on how uh uh
you know that law was established you
know she's connecting some dots that
simply are not there and
and i have expressed this in the four or
five times that this bill has been
before the legislature in the past
and the two court cases uh sumner v
secretary of state that she took all of
the away to the supreme court twice
uh and the
she lost in every every court along the
way
uh citing these same issues
so why is it important that ballots are
are
exempt from the right to know law and
they are to be kept private
first
there is a process after an election
where it is very easy for a candidate
involved in the election to request a
recount
after the recount is over if there are
still
unresolved issues
the the candidate can appeal to the
ballot law commission
the ballot law commission will review
whatever evidence it is that the
candidates bring forward
in determining the final outcome of the
race
and when they make a decision
that's it
after that ballots are sealed and they
are not to be reopened unless there's an
act of the legislature
and that currently is underway in the
windham situation that uh you heard
mentioned before or unless a court says
open the ballots
they have to find that there is a valid
reason for doing so but a court can do
that
it is incredibly important that there is
finality to the election after it's over
so that the elected
officials can assume their office
and uh and carry on their work in new
hampshire they have very little time to
do that job as all of you know
you you hold your position for two years
and then you're up for election again
and and you get to go through the cycle
all over again
we all know that that there are groups
and agencies and
and entities out there that will do
surveys in polls and the outcome of
those polls
can be biased i mean the the they can
come up with findings that suit their
positions
over somebody else's
based on looking at the same information
the same would be true
if we allowed groups to go in
and assess what happened with uh you
know with the ballots in election they
can they can use different standards for
counting the ballots in a race and the
conclusions can be different from
another group they may want to look at
those ballots and do the same thing
that is not helpful all that does is so
doubt into the into the outcome of the
election
uh which should already have been
decided that is a very important public
interest that
we need to uphold
the other issue
that comes to mind is the privacy of the
voter
there are ballots that if they are
opened up can be tied to a voter
and the easy examples to make are
ballots that we receive back from our
military and overseas personnel
um and uh
those are ballots that they receive
electronically
when they're overseas or or
doing their military service
they print the ballot off on using
whatever paper they have on whatever
printer they have and whatever font is
being used the ballots are printed they
fill them out and then they have to mail
them in
the ballot is unique and there may be a
way to tie that ballot to the voter that
cast it
in similar fashion we have accessible
voting equipment in the polling places
um
that has come a long way so that those
ballots are now actual ballots and a
ballot marking device uh is used on
those ballots
the ballot marking device does a very
clean job filling in the oval but to the
extent that you can see that that oval
has been uh marked by uh that device
and let's say you have five or six or
eight
voters that
use that device and you can identify
you can identify those ballots
if all of those voters voted the same
way for a particular office
you can identify how a voter that used
that device
voted
that's inappropriate
i have personally seen ballots where the
voter has gone in and actually sign
their name to them
that is uh not legal because you're not
supposed to put identifying marks on the
ballot
but there are voters that feel strongly
about their vote they actually sign the
ballot
that would be visible under this type of
an inspection
and then the next the next item that i
will move on to is is actually a form of
voter fraud that was prevalent in the
late 1800s
before there was a movement
across the united states including new
hampshire
to reform the election balance
vote buying was a very common procedure
prior to the to the 1893-1894
period where
the ballots were not printed by the
state they were actually printed by the
candidates or the political parties
and a voter would walk in and
and they would cast the party ticket for
example they would they could hold up
the ballot when they went into the
polling place so that
voters could see that ballot before it
got dropped into the box
and party officials knowing that seeing
that could give the payoff for that
voter once once that was done
a similar a similar type of activity
could occur
if we allow anybody to go in after an
election and review the ballots and it
would be simply as saying
uh you know i wanna i want your vote i'm
willing to pay you ten dollars for it
um and here's what i want you to do
i want you to vote for
so and so for uh president or governor
and then on the right in line for county
commissioner i want you to write in
josiah bartlett
and when i have the opportunity then to
open those ballots and go back through
them
when i find josiah bartlett and i see
that there were votes cast the way that
that i wanted to see them for president
and governor
uh i could hand off the ten dollars
and make your payment
um again that certainly is not in the
public interest and is a primary reason
why
ballast should remain
[Music]
private and confidential
one way to address the concerns that
have been raised is to come up with a
meaningful audit process
after an election is over of of not only
machine count towns but also hand count
towns
um that process does not exist it has
been proposed several times in the past
but there has never been agreement on on
what that process would look like
um
i i think that uh
that pretty much covers everything that
i've covered in the past on this topic
but i just wanted to reiterate that
there are very valid reasons for
the practice
of not making the ballots public
after an election
and we would encourage this committee in
the legislature to find this bill and
expedient the legislate
any questions with deputy stanland from
committee members here in the globe and
representative
thank you mr chairman uh deputy chairman
are you aware of any other states that
allow this and is there anything in
federal law that allows or prohibits
this
uh we're
growing i believe that there are other
states that
that make the ballots after the election
um
uh available to the public
you know each st each state has its own
election system
um and uh
you know i think that each state would
have to be reviewed individually to see
if that practice makes
sense or not there are there are many
states that are now counting their
ballots using digital scanning
technology where an actual image of the
ballot is stored on the computer new
hampshire does not do that
because we use optical scan
the digital scan states
it can actually isolate the individual
marks on the ballot so that you don't
have to look at the ballot itself uh in
aggregate but you can see how the marks
are being made and
it will identify marks that are
unusual and
and need some adjudication to determine
what the voter intent was
on them so
that that information is stored in some
states and is available
uh in others
thank you
any other questions from my members here
in the committee room to deputy scandal
anyone participating remotely you have
any questions
thank you deputy stanley thank you
nice
raise
[Music]
next time
there you go thank you
hi mr chairman and i am the election
committee
can do
volumes offer
can you hear me now
how about everybody else i can barely
hear you
huh
i'm right next to the computer
can you hear me now
listen carefully
okay
my name is chao kelly and i'm from
hooksett new hampshire and i would like
to support
hb480 and it's important for us we the
people to have faith
in our election
because
we have to be able let's say somebody
give me a fake bill for like a dollar
bill and i say this is fake so the other
person should be able to hold that fake
bill or real bill we have to hold it and
inspect it not through a computer not
through an image
and the the explanation from that last
gentleman saying like some people they
for military they sign up and stuff like
that their privacy is important but that
is a small percentage and the privacy
and the public trust weight is way off
so we do need to have access
to this ballot directly
and it's not just
for the candidate that lost a win the
public have a vast
interest in this process of who they
voted for that representing them so it's
not just personally to those candidates
that involved is involved to the whole
public and we the people have the right
to know and touch those ballots
thank you
questions to ms kelly from members here
on the payroll
questions from committee members
participating remotely
thank you very much thank you
also uh
penn barnes has uh
his hand raised
mr barnes
oh good am i unmuted yes
that's great thanks so much i mr
chairman and member of the committee i
appreciate your
allowing me to speak at this important
hearing
i support hb 480 and i hope you will
vote it out of committee ought to pass
uh it's
very important to our democracy i think
the greatest gift that we as americans
and we as granite staters have
is the democracy
that
we are
blessed to live under and the key to to
making a democracy functional is
voting
fair elections and our ability to
actually
the pup for the people of the state to
choose who the
represent who our representatives will
be and who will be making the policies
that govern our lives
and
i
think that the importance of election
integrity is not only crucial to public
trust of the process as a lot of
speakers have said because it certainly
would go a long way to restoring public
trust but we have a long way to go after
that public trust isn't just about
transparency but
without transparency
we
can't know whether
the
election process has actually
produced the right results we can
uh
the machines are fallible machines are
always fallible and uh in particular
uh the counting process is fallible
uh the the recent example of windham
demonstrates
that
we who may have taken
the voting machines for granted
were wrong and
in fact
there are huge errors whether it changes
the outcome of the election in this
particular election is not the point the
point is
that the machine counting process
is
potentially fallible as
the woman who was the former republican
candidate
uh talked about you know you get results
that are anonymous anomalous and but for
somebody
either requesting a recount or
some other way
we'll never know unless the public
is there to
inspect and oversee the vote count
the
uh scanners make mistakes and uh
can't be relied on and
the people
being present
who
look at the ballot uh the woman who just
testified talked about uh we have the
right to see and touch the ballots it's
it's
uh she's absolutely right on
the
access part it's not but it's not about
touching them it's about
assuring the public that
uh the vote
cap that's reported
is
what the voters actually wanted and
voted for
and i just have to say that uh in
response to uh
the speaker from the secretary of
state's office deputy scanlan
um you know he
uh gave us a parade of horribles of
things that could
go wrong and those are the usual
parade which is trotted out against any
kind of public access
government
accountability but government
transparency uh and government
um it's always a little harder to be in
a democracy it's always a little harder
to
have the people
to whom our elected officials are
responsible they rep you all represent
us after all
um
it's harder and as somebody said it may
cost a little more money but
uh
the process
of a democracy
is worth
a little more we our chaotic election
season
you know some people around the world
think we're crazy as americans to
uh
put up with all of this
huge expense and uh chaotic
give and take back and forth
um but that's what a democracy is it
doesn't not that it should be uh with
personal invective but we have a robust
debate and then we transition
power and
move
move on and the will of the people is
put into place with representatives like
you folks and
that is
why it's worth putting up with all the
chaos and the expense that we americans
and grant staters put up with to to
participate
in
a fair voting system
the
this particular bill 480
talking about public
uh access to the ballots to
uh check and make sure they're
accurately counted
is the alternative to the alternative
that the secretary of state's office
wants is to
how did he put it um
a candidate can request a recount
and if it's denied
uh
by uh the town
the recount
that it goes to um the ballot commission
and the bow commission decides yay or
nay and then it's over
and uh mr scanlan said it has to be over
it's very important to be over quickly
because otherwise uh it'll drag out and
you representatives won't be able to
take office and do your jobs well i
suggest to you that the
the georgia secretary of state
[Music]
showed us very clearly that
it doesn't have to drag out and take
forever to
uh have
uh public checking of the accuracy of
ballots they did
three recounts hand recounts of every
single ballot of millions of ballots and
they were done in a matter of weeks uh
didn't
so in our state uh the the boogeyman of
uh
representatives uh will
not be able to take their office and do
their jobs if
the dirty public comes in and
looks over the ballots and and checks
for accuracy that's just not reality and
i don't think the committee should be
scared by that
uh parade of horribles so i i
uh
ask you to please vote ought to pass on
hb480
thank you very much
and thank you for listening
sorry i took so long
thank you mr barnes i understand
um that we are here
finishing up the hearing on house bill
480 my name is barbara griffin i'm chair
of the committee thank you for everybody
for indulgence in regards to the morning
we are significantly behind schedule
which was not expected i have we have a
hearing scheduled for 10 30 with over
400 people expected
to be logged on
so i am sort of trying to i walked onto
this meeting much earlier this morning
so in regards to port 80
um
i'm going to ask and i don't quite have
my program up but i i'm going to ask the
vice chair how many more people want to
speak on this bill because they get a
minute
okay we have each of you um given that
this hearing has taken an hour and 15
minutes um in the schedule this morning
um why don't you recognize one of those
people for
a minute thank you
hey representative gay i will promote
your analyst
thank you very much and this won't take
me a minute to tell you can you hear me
now
yes we can representative gay proceed
thank you
okay i certainly support this bill and i
had no idea in the four years that i was
on election law that there were so many
discrepancies going on in hand counting
and i cause always are up in salem it's
all machine counted and i forgot that
you still have to do some hand counting
and after going to a recount that's very
carefully supervised by the secretary of
state's office in concord and it was so
impressive how it is carefully done and
well observed
it just didn't dawn on me that we didn't
get that kind of care
guaranteed in all the towns that
do have all count hand count and some so
please support house bill 480. thank you
representative mcdonald's what's next
please
thank you
police are you if you want yourself you
may testify
lisa
all right next speaker please
can you hear me now yes we can felicia
thank you welcome to the election
committee
hospital 480.
um i am in support of the house bill 480
and i just wanted to briefly suggest a
suggestion
um to
redact the names on the ballads so that
we could decisively confirm
whether or not it was human error or
something different causing these
anomalies as the previous speaker just
said it's something um that is prevalent
in some time in some towns and and not
in ours
i yield the floor thank you
thank you very much representative
mcdonald's who's next uh no one else uh
asked him to speak
thank you very much well actually it's
uh
bill smith and phil smith
mr smith welcome to the election lock
committee minute
mr smith promoted to panelists
mr smith we believe that you are a
panelist if you
unmute yourself you should be with us
hello uh sorry this is bill smith can
you hear me now
mr smith thank you go ahead
thank you um i am in support of this
bill election integrity is essential
should votes be counted accurately or
are large error rates okay i think the
answer is obvious large vote tally
errors of the type uncovered in the
windham recount should cause us all
great concern an error pattern that
systematically disfavors republican
candidates and favors a democrat
candidate looks suspicious we must
determine how these large errors happen
might this have been caused by
malfunctioning voting machines if so
due to erroneous software algorithms or
deliberately misprogrammed algorithms or
were the numbers manually changed
somehow and if so by whom
computer software is a key area of
security vulnerability software is a
black box unless we have access to the
source code we do not know exactly what
it does
is software driven voting machines
reliable do they count consistently and
accurately the windham machines must be
tested in a methodical and public way to
see if the erroneous counts are
repeatable on these machines
if the machines are proven to count
consistently and accurately then what
might the election's original vote
tallies have been altered elsewhere
thank you mr smith that is your minute
do what i understand and my recollection
is you actually did submit what you were
speaking and written testimony to the
committee
thank you
thank
you representative mcdonald do we have
someone else on 480. not i do not have
anyone else who has not already spoken
all right so
thank you very much everybody uh i'm
going to close the hearing on 480 my
apologies to everybody for my late
appearance here this morning i'm going
to open the hearing on house bill 491
relative to overgrowing phallus
um the prime sponsor and i'm having to
rely on my vice chair thank you very
much is representative porter
um and i understand
that
porter has signed up to speak and
to get me logged on to this evening i
really need to be logged on for
490 for sb 22 and i having problems
i'll call somebody right away
thank you madam chair can you hear you
folks hear me now i can
i feel like i'm on a cell phone
commercial
good morning madam chair members of the
committee it's good to see you all again
for the record my name is marjorie
porter and i represent hillsborough
district one the people of antrim
hillsborough in windsor and i'm here to
introduce this bill to you
back in the days when i taught and
administered standardized machine scored
tests to the children the directions i
read told them
if they changed their answers to make
sure to completely erase the oval they
had marked incorrectly or else their
answer would be marked wrong
also never make stray marks on that
answer sheet the machine can't read your
mind
this always comes to mind when i think
about over voted ballots
as you know an overboat happens when
there are marks in both ovals in a
two-person race for example
either by accident or due to a voter
changing her mind
sometimes voters will put a big x
through that wrong vote and just move on
down the ballot
when ballots are hand counted the poll
workers can see that x and give the vote
to the other candidate
with vote counting machines however a
problem is created if there are marks in
both ovals the machine reads it as an
overvote and unfortunately in new
hampshire now the machine accepts the
ballot but does not count that vote
the voter and the candidate they chose
lose that vote
however our machines can be programmed
to reject that over voted ballot
spitting it back to the voter so
corrections can be made
in fact in massachusetts and vermont we
use the same type of machines that we
use that is exactly what they do
the voter can then make corrections or
simply place it into a separate ballot
box to be hand counted later
this bill requires that our vote
counting machines be programmed in that
same way
so voters have a chance to fix the error
if they made one
what is particularly concerning to me
now
is there is some evidence which others
who are testifying later will explain
that in november the november election a
quite large percentage of absentee
ballots were counted as overvoted by
some of our machines
this is possibly because the folds in
those ballots created shadows that the
machine read as marx
we had some very close races in november
and it's possible these votes could have
changed the outcome
every voter's vote counts
especially in these times it is vital
that every voter's vote is counted
no one should be disenfranchised because
they made a mistake changed their mind
made a stray mark or folded their ballot
to fit into an envelope
and i hope you will favorably consider
hb 491
and madam chair there are some people
behind me who have more details who have
done the research on this and have more
details and might be able to answer
questions better than i can but i'll
give it a try
thank you
does anybody in the community room have
a question representative
[Music]
thank you madam chair
uh how do you anticipate this will be
handled in towns that do not use the
electronic ballot counting machines
towns where
the votes are hand counted
i would anticipate that they would not
have this this problem the machines are
what's
causing the problem usually with a hand
counted ballot you can look at it and
make a determination of what the voter
intended with that vote
i have a follow-up man follow-up
wouldn't that mean that the the people
at the in the communities that do hand
counts would have to see the ballot of
the
voter right at that moment and wouldn't
that violate their privacy
i no representative i don't believe so
because what we're asking is that the
machines be reprogrammed so that they
will spit out over voted ballots it
doesn't pertain to hand counted ballots
at all
thank you further questions for
committee members representative
thank you madam chair thank you
representative take my question
certainly all voters have a right to
vote
but with that right comes a
responsibility to be informed and follow
the directions on the ballot um
so my question is
it seems if this legislation passes some
people will get a second chance to
correct an error they may have made but
others may not for example i could see
with the absentee ballot
individual
getting
the chance to be contacted to get that
potential error they may change that
somebody else that voted in person
probably wouldn't so how do you justify
the
franchise you know
maybe over franchising one group and
under franchising another if this
legislation passes
well i believe in the legislation um
it's online 10 it says ballots of
absentee voters and those who choose not
to correct or replace the ballot shall
be placed in an auxiliary compartment
and counted by election officials
so
that would be how it would be handled
but you know to be honest it's easy to
make a stray mark on a ballot it was
easy for those kids in school to put
their pencil down too hard and make a
mark on the wrong answer and believe me
i looked over my kids test scores my
test
papers after they had been scored
by machine and i saw one of them had a
raw ex
incorrect answer when i looked at his
paper it was because there was a stray
market it was very light but the machine
read it as a wrong answer so it does
happen that way uh no fault of the of
the voter
or no change in his mind just a stray
mark on the paper
thank you further questions from people
in the committee room
members online
i need you to speak up if you're online
i have a question madam chair
representative mooney here
if you're able to hear me
yes we are go ahead
thank you thank you chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
uh you're absolutely right that voters
do make mistakes on their ballots
can you tell me if a voter
is aware that they've made a mistake do
they have an option
of notifying somebody at the polls
uh getting a new ballot having that one
marked and if so how does that relate to
your bill
representative thank you for the
question i do think they have that
option but that option is not told to
them when they're handed their ballot um
for example when i go in and get my
ballot and i mark it no one has ever
said to me representative marjorie you
can get a new ballot if you make a
mistake so
don't worry i go in i mark my ballot and
i put it away um
i'm not sure that members of the public
might be aware that they could ask for a
second ballot
to fix it um so
unless that's specifically stated to
them at some point when they're handed
their ballot
i don't think they a lot of people would
know that
thank you thank you
further questions from the committee
i'm not hearing any i'm almost to the
point where i can see if there are any
so
um thank you madam chair thank you
representative porter for coming um we
had 15 minutes allocated for this
hearing we are already into it
um 10 minutes we have three more people
signed up to speak i'm going to
recognize mary till
for two minutes
you could come up there until that would
be great
mm-hmm morning miss tell you
mu you are with us
i have somebody signed on as malia till
but they are muted if you unmute we will
hear from you
okay we're going to move on
um also sign up to speak on this bill is
deborah sumner
morning a summoner
you have two minutes you will be
promoted by
vice chair wayne mcdonald
i'm i'm unmuted now madame chair this is
mary malyatil
oh is that well thanks for clearing that
up for me miss chill all right
um here's my nickname
wait for a minute we'll hear from miss
till for two minutes thank you
go ahead
thank you madam chair my name is mary
till i'm from derry new hampshire and i
rise in support of house bill 491
as dairytown moderator from 2016 to 2020
i am very familiar with the problem of
overvoted ballots
in counting votes moderators are
guided by the standard of the intent of
the voter
this standard was recognized by the new
hampshire supreme court in 2003 in the
mcdonald case and is further reinforced
by the secretary of state in the
election procedure manual
in derry in november 2020 one of the
accu-vote machines that exclusively
processed absentee ballots recorded over
votes on more than
570 ballots
taken together the eight accuvote
machines used in derry recorded nearly
850 over-voted ballots
these are big numbers and if they all or
most of them impact the same race as
with a crease they could easily swing an
election
section 301 of the help america vote act
specifically calls out this issue
it requires that the voter be notified
of the problem informed of the
consequences and given an opportunity to
correct the problem including completing
a new ballot
new hampshire could easily and quickly
instruct lhs to
include code it has already created for
massachusetts and vermont to return an
overvoted ballot the secretary of state
has resisted requesting this
this code because he says he does not
want to embarrass the voter whose ballot
is returned
really
i don't know about you i'd rather have
the problem point it out to me than lose
my vote
besides the evidence indicates
that the intent of the voter is clear on
the vast majority of so-called overvotes
the problem is the machine reading error
this is a serious issue with an easy
solution it is time to take steps to
make sure that every vote counts please
vote ought to pass on house bill 491
i'll be happy to answer any questions
you may have and will send a copy of my
full testimony to the clerk to be
included in the record thank you miss
till it sounded like you had written
testimony so thank you for sending a
question of representative cooper
o'brien thank you madam chair
uh thank you for taking my question ms
till
my question is
uh am i first of all am i correct that
not every community uses electronic
ballot counting machines in new
hampshire and how
would voters in those communities that
do not use electronic ballot counting
machines
be given the same opportunity that that
those with uh electronic ballot counting
machines would have under this
bill well the bill is designed to
deal with an issue that is specific to
electronic ballot counting machines and
the towns that use them
people who vote in hand count towns
already have the opportunity to have
their ballot reviewed by
election officials and as i pointed out
in my testimony the vast vast majority
of over voted ballots or so-called
overvoted ballots
are not the fault of the voter but
rather an inability of the machine to
read the intention of the voter
thank you further questions
representative o'brien thank you a
follow-up on that how exactly would they
have it reviewed does that mean that
every voter who brings their ballot
to the to the ballot box in a
town that does hand counts not
electronic not using electronic ballot
counting machines that the
the moderator or election officials on
site look at their ballot when they pass
it in
they look they look at their ballots
after the election is closed and the
hand count begins a hand count means
that
human beings look at the ballot and
decide what the voter intent was for
each race
thank you miss till point taken i
believe any other questions for his till
online our president in the committee
room i think i've got my computer stuff
together everybody so
if you wait for on you i will see it
all right thank you miss till ms sumner
you have been uh
promoted to a panelist if you on view we
will be we welcome your testimony and
you have two minutes thank you
okay i was prepared to speak for five
minutes and i will try to um hit the
high spots you do have copies of my
testimony i thought i saw something from
you so why don't we just have two
minutes of the high spots and that would
be a big thing i'll i'll you can cut me
off when you think i've gone too far
i'll put you back for two minutes just
mention that the second time that i went
to court was to find out why 2.5 percent
of jeffrey ballon
and i also want to respond to some prior
questions mr you just got very very
faint i can't hear you well can you hear
me can you hear me now
i haven't done i haven't been saying
it's not minutes miss sumner i can't
hear you
um let me let me try to speak a little
louder and see if that helps yeah
now you're back okay go ahead
okay there was a question in terms of um
hand count towns and optical scan towns
there has been research done in terms of
which technology
produces the the fewest number of
overvoted ballots and the research that
has been done shows that hand count
towns and optical scans when they are
programmed to return those over voted
ballots have the lowest rate of
overvotes the touch screens the punch
card ballots
the lever machines all had higher
overvotes than the optical scan
programmed and hand counts the other
issue in terms of new hampshire is that
when we were using the lever machines
and this goes back to 1800s
the law required those lever machines
not to allow over voted ballots all
right that was one of the sales pitches
for buying the lever machines is it did
not allow voters to vote for too many
candidates
okay so back to my testimony here okay
the problem currently
is that new hampshire has two
contradictory
policies rsa 659 colon 6-4
voter intent is the legal standard in
new hampshire and every other state that
i'm aware of
the secretary of state's policy
is
or mr scanlon mr fitch and i interpret
the federal requirement differently but
i believe we agree neither the new
hampshire attorney general nor the u.s
department of justice is enforcing the
law saying this is a policy question for
the legislature to decide
the research anecdotal evidence shows
less experienced voters those of lower
income and education are more likely to
be disenfranchised by over voted ballots
this has been known since the 2000
general election and reported by the
election assistance commission and i can
give you a specific example from jeffrey
if you're interested ms sumner if you
could give those in the written
testimony that would be terrific you
have 15 seconds
um i think representative porter
mentioned in terms of the educational
aspects of it and the data okay we've
asked the attorney general to
investigate derry of why there were so
many overvoted ballots
you have received copy of that
communication of that request he has not
responded at all other than he had
received the request all right so we
have an enforcement problem and we don't
know why there were so many overvoted
ballots we just know that a lot of
people in derry lost their votes
for one or more contests and there's no
way to know uh how or why that happened
if you could finish up please that would
be terrific
november 2016 races and you can see um
the information in the packet
he acknowledged two to three percent of
all ballots are not read by the scanner
are legal votes
and you can see the margin of victory
for the president u.s and governor's
race in 2016.
all of those came within that two to
three percent possibility that over
votes alone might have caused a
different winner in each of those three
contests thank you for that background
excuse me i have one more thing
representative griffin i did sign up for
uh five minutes and i've spent a lot of
time on this issue thank you very much
and i'm sure you'll give mr scanlon all
the time he needs to respond
okay i'm going to just add on here what
i hope he will improve in the bill
representative porter was very good in
putting this in at the last minute there
were some things that would make this
bill better and that's on page two
that's what i hope you will add to the
bill to improve it to make it comparable
to what connecticut vermont and
massachusetts are all doing now for
their voters we deserve the same
respect for our votes as those states
are showing for theirs
thank you very much and i'm guessing
that no one has any questions
and yes i'm upset thank you
i appreciate that you're upset mrs
sumner i unfortunately was not able to
conduct the public hearings today we
have a full agenda
and i am grateful you do submit written
testimony to the election law committee
quite frequently and it is all always
educational and has information in it
does anybody on the committee have
questions for ms sumner
i'm not seeing or hearing any
so thank you
for being with us
this morning also signed up to speak on
this bill this morning is mr barnes uh
representative mcdonald is mr barnes
here
mr barnes if you're here can you raise
your hand
i'm not
there you are
mr barnes
is you're being promoted if you unmute
welcome to the committee and you have
two minutes
i i couldn't unmute it
wouldn't let me on you know i'm sorry
um i won't take even my full two minutes
you can give it to somebody else but i
ask you to vote this bill off to pass
it's very important and uh
the
reasons stated by uh
the sponsor
and
ms sumner uh support the bill thank you
very much
thank you mr barnes for indicating your
support
um that is the end of the people who are
able to sign up before the hearing began
i also have chao kelly with the hand up
for this hearing
um i am promoting
to
a panelist and
welcome to the election law chad kelly
if you were there i hope that i have
promoted you and if you want me you can
speak
you have two minutes
where did
hello
there you are good morning you have two
minutes welcome
oh hi uh yes um thank you for allowing
me to speak my name is ciao kelly and
i'm from hooksett new hampshire and i'm
here to support
hb 491 and i would like to say that
if it is all possible
um you know it would be great for all of
us americans to have
hand counting everything and no machine
please because the technologies
is like too advanced
that we the regular citizens have no
idea of what it can do like for example
my credit card can just be in my pocket
and somebody can just walk by and they
can just steal all of my information and
that that's a couple years old
information already and most people out
there don't even know that so we don't
know what these machines doing we don't
know what these software that they
update are doing so we have no clue so
we would prefer
hand counting if possible please thank
you
thank you very much for joining us this
morning and your testimony does anybody
have any questions for ms kelly
anybody online or here in the committee
room
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for being with us
gay i believe you i've been promoted to
a panelist
um that was my intent
and if you unmute you will be with us
and
you have two minutes
let's see if i can find you
can you find representative
gay you are with us
i'm finally here my computer's doing
weird things it won't take me a whole
minute to tell you oh i'm upside down
too
it won't take a minute to tell you that
this sounds like a great bill and all
the for all the reasons that have been
told to us and the fact that i'm not
worried anymore about somebody's privacy
being in
embarrassed if by a machine kicking out
a bill uh of
a
a ballot because there's ways to keep
that private there's there's a way to
shield that and the person it's going to
be so fast that a person could be
standing there and you just say wait a
second
because
it's obvious that some of the reasons
it's not somebody being careless and
voting for too many people it's because
of the machine reading reading something
incorrectly so i think it's a really
good idea so please vote for 491 thank
you
thank you representative gay any
questions for representative gay
i'm not seeing any here in the committee
room i'm not hearing anybody online so
thank you very much
um also with the hand up and this is the
last hand i've seen
um is deputy scanlan deputy stanley you
should be with us if you and you welcome
on fortnite you have two minutes to be
fit
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm david scanlan deputy
secretary of state and i'm here in
opposition to house bill 491
uh earlier in testimony you heard that
section 301 of the help america vote act
requires that overvoted absentee ballots
be rejected what you were not told is
that there is an exemption that applies
to the state of new hampshire
in section b that says a state or
jurisdiction that uses a paper ballot
voting system which new hampshire does
may meet the requirements
by establishing a voter education
program specific to that voting system
that notifies each voter of the effect
of casting multiple votes for an office
and providing the voter with
instructions on how to correct the
ballot before it is cast and counted
new hampshire does both of those things
when a voter receives their ballot i
have a copy right here this section up
here is the instructions to voters on
how to mark their ballot and what
happens if they
market improperly additionally when the
voter goes into the voting booth there's
one of these
informational posters that are that
should be hanging in the booth which
does the same thing so
new hampshire does satisfy the
requirements that allow us to have an
exemption from that provision of the
help america vote act
uh
representative doma brian touched on the
other really important component of this
issue and that is if you allow overvotes
to be rejected
uh by a machine
so that the voter can correct the
mistake
you are recl you are creating different
classes of voters in the state of new
hampshire
a voter that is voting on a hand count
paper ballot makes their marks
the ballot gets folded it's handed it to
the moderator and that ballot gets
dropped in the box the moderator does
not open that ballot up and look at it
and inform the voter if they've over
voted giving the voter an opportunity to
go back and fix their ballot that simply
does not happen that ballot whether the
voter over voted on or not goes in the
box and gets counted at the end of the
night
the same thing is true of voters that
vote by absentee whether it's in a hand
count town or whether it's in a machine
count town when they over vote or if
they ever vote on their ballot that's
the way it is they do not have another
opportunity to correct
any issues so to make sure that voters
are treated the same way uniformly
across the board new hampshire does not
reject the overvoted ballots that go
through the machine i think that's under
two minutes mountain chair i'll be happy
to answer any questions a little bit
over but the timer is going to go off in
five but so i'm gonna
say ask if anybody here in the committee
room has a question for deputy scanlon
does anybody attending online you have a
question for deputy scam
i'm not seeing anybody
but
also signed up
the
hand raised to speak on this bill
um that has not spoken
is marilyn todd
miss todd uh i have asked my computer to
promote you to
be able to speak and indeed you can and
if you are new you are with us you have
two minutes
can you hear me we're all set we can
hear you thank you
um with all due respect i i don't think
that the secretary of state's office
should have any kind of say in this
matter due to their lack of action and
integrity
no offense i just don't they haven't
done anything
to
the public to make us feel
safe by any of their positions they
haven't this is the first time we've
heard them weigh in and that's all i
wanted to say thank you
thank you
is till you've already spoken on this
bill is there anybody who has not spoken
on this bill that would like to
i'm not seeing any so miss till i am
going to close the public hearing i
appreciate that you want something else
to say but in fairness to the other
people who spoke that i timed
um if you have written testimony that
you would like to submit um the election
committee is quite good about getting
emails and reading them so thank you
very much i am going to close the public
hearing on 491.
the next public hearing that is
scheduled for this morning is house bill
524 this is requiring the secretary of
state to conduct planning verification
of polling place recounts this bill has
a defined sponsor representative lange
um representative wang joins us in the
committee room this morning to introduce
the bill as i understand he was sent
here for other maddox this morning so
representative today welcome
thank you mr chairman i will keep this
real shirt because i know you're behind
um
the text of the bills
you want you're welcome to sit in the
center seat with your back either to me
or the camera or you can make if you
don't mind i'll just stay right here so
it's easier to see everybody i can see
the screen
representative so people know where you
are because the screen is sort of hard
to see
all right thank you
thank you uh representative tim lang
representing belknap four which are the
towns of tilton sanderton i'm also a
town moderator for the town of san
britain have been so for nearly a decade
now
um that makes me feel old um so this
bill is pretty straightforward i'm not
going to walk through the details um i'm
sure you could read it just ask me
questions if you'd like
but what this bill does is just it's i
consider an election integrity bill um
in a in a november 2020 nbc news poll
56 of americans decided they were not
confident in the election process in
that polling summary
um
in reading that kind of activity i'm
looking at how we can possibly restore
faith in the electoral process and i
think one of the things we always look
at in almost everything we do in the
legislature especially when we're
involving money and things that are
important because we do an audit um so
this bill just allows a verification
pound of polling places to act as an
audit um but we know that there is an
issue with faith you know in the process
and the goal is to have this bill act as
a as a fix for that and to start
restoring faith in the process by having
a
quantitative and qualitative proof
of election integrity in the ballots by
having uh these verification accounts
done immediately following the election
um i will be happy to take questions but
i think like i said the bill itself is
pretty straightforward
uh thank you anybody in the committee
room who has a question
i'm not seeing any representative mooney
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question
and sponsoring the bill uh my question
is this say for example a district
requests a recount an individual
requests a recount could that be
considered one of the random locations
chosen by the
sos
so
i would say if it happened to be
selected by the set uh by the secretary
of state as one of his is random um
options and then somebody request while
the recount period starts after this
process starts after the recompense but
again um
they could use that but understand that
this recount is not of a single race so
this verification vote uh count is not
of a single race it's of the entire
ballot um because as we know and i i was
educated last night by the vice chairman
in the last 50 years we've only had two
statewide recounts
and that occurred in the 90s and in the
70s
it's never been done it rarely is done
when you take an office like a
congressional district or governor's
race or a presidential race um they're
not recounting so we actually have no
real data on what recounts look like in
those races by doing this verification
vote it would it would capture all races
on that ballot
further questions from committee members
thank you madam chairman uh thank you
for taking my question representative
lang this is
a question related to uh line six excuse
me in line five
where it says immediately preceding each
state general election
i'm not sure i understand what that word
means in that context proceeding
so it is immediately following you after
so as soon as the election is done
if you look at the um line 24 on there
it talks about the verification count
needs to be completed 21 days post
election within that period of time from
when the election ends and 21 days later
i just wasn't sure what the word
proceeding that that context thank you
any other questions from community
members representatives
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative lang
why did you choose five there is none
done now and then it just jumped up to
five but
where did that number come from thank
you for your question so again in 2020
we had over 800 thousand ballots cast
and the record in the state of new
hampshire um i used a two percent margin
saying i wanted if we were to count two
percent of those ballots what number
would that be
and if you do the math based on the
number of five polling places in the way
we've broken it up the minimum number if
the secretary of state took the easiest
score possible he would hit 17 500
ballots would be hand-counted
and that would represent just over two
percent of the uh
of the ballots total cast in the 2020
election
a follow-up thank you
so
you say the easiest path do you mean if
communities that were very small were
chosen that would equal
500 what if
larger communities were chosen because
this is done randomly so what if it was
nashua manchester conquered derry
portsmouth so again if you in the in the
context of the bill and maybe i should
have went through it um there are five
basis places selected one of which has
to be a polling place between two
thousand and four thousand another one
has to be a polling place between four
thousand and seventy five hundred
another one has to be above seventy five
hundred the other two could be any any
towns of any size so if you take the
minimum numbers which is two thousand
four thousand seventy five hundred you
had those and then he added two more
small towns of two thousand each you
still get the seventeen thousand five
hundred ballots being counted
further questions from the committee
representative o'brien next question
thank you how long would this take our
state officials to do so in the in the
uh fiscal note that's attached the
secretary of state's office says he
would need eight teams to do this and he
could do it one week
um
thank you representative for introducing
bill
also signed up to speak on this bill is
actually with their hand raised
is
representative of asyro i
recognize your representative barbacero
and you have two minutes
representative paul desar you are with
us and if you want you we're set to go
okay thank you uh this is representative
madam chair and this is representative
albal the sow rock damn county district
five londonderry and i am uh testifying
from an undisclosed location
um
but anyways i i i definitely support of
this bill and one of the reasons why and
i'm going to be quick is
i've got more phone calls from people
questioning the integrity of our vote
that has gone on in the past
and whether it's uh fair election or
whether it's not we'll never know
i think the secretary of state uh needed
this authorization because like wyndham
i was there for the recount they should
have been somebody should have been on
that right then and there a week later
and got wyndham done the overvotes in
derry should have been uh audited right
off the bat uh so this is a long overdue
bill and i definitely support and i
thank representative blaine for bringing
it forward and that's all i have thank
you thank you representative
any questions for representative
besides what the temperature is
[Applause]
mr barnes i am promoting you to panelist
if you can unmute we'd love to hear from
you for two minutes
uh i'll be brief i
support
this bill and random audits i would like
to
have faith in the secretary of state's
office to do random audits that are
thorough and
protect the accuracy of the boats
again as i said earlier this morning i
believe that the machine count votes are
subject to
well tampering fraud mistake error
and all kinds of uh inaccuracies that
will undermine or could
undermine
the uh accuracy of the vote count and
and that means of our democracy and
the more
checking that there is on the accuracy
of the vote that the better
i supported the voters the public's
rights to come and uh review
the uh
ballots as well and i think that random
checks from the secretary of state's
office
would also
not only be able to catch some
machine errors
but also
would
gets served as a deterrent to districts
to to
uh districts to use
machines that are not subject to
such issues
as somebody mentioned in an earlier
hearing the
software of the machines
is the biggest problem it's proprietary
software usually nobody knows what
what's in it how it works or who can
tamper with it
and just to have some
actual checks on it
and shedding some light on errors like
occurred in windham
i think
it's a good thing to
have public checks on the machines thank
you that will yield no time and
i appreciate you hearing me
hope you vote for pass
thank you mr barnes for staying with us
this morning does anybody have any
questions for mr barnes
i see none in the committee room and i'm
not seeing any on screen
so thank you very much for joining us oh
sorry i thought i had turned you off
um
also signed up to speak on this bill is
mary till
um
miss till i am promoting you to
panelists if you can fund you you should
be with us
can you hear me i can thank you welcome
two minutes
thank you thank you madam chair so my
name is still mary jill and i'm from
derry i rise in support of house bill
524 i applaud representative lang's
effort to address the need to verify the
machine count after the election it is
long past time
that we stop blindly
that the machine count is infallible
i would like to share some suggestions
for strengthening the bill
one to remove any suspicion that the
secretary of state purposely selected
favorable polling places i suggest that
all the polling places be publicly and
randomly selected within the criteria
described in the bill
second if the secretary of state is
given 21 days to complete the
verification count the law needs to
define what happens if a different
winner is identified perhaps we should
delay the final certification date until
after the verification count
third the bill calls for further
investigation if a two percent
difference is found most highly
contested races in new hampshire result
in differences of far less than two
percent perhaps one percent is a better
standard and finally the average number
of ballots involved because of their
criteria allowed and allowed in the bill
representative lang indicated with 17
500 minimum an average of at least 20
000 and as he pointed out
with 12 races on each ballot it could
take days to finish the recount this
raises a couple of issues if the counts
are to occur in concord over multiple
days the likelihood of public oversight
will be minimal people have jobs and
lives to attend to also to
the um
the number the designated races would be
randomly selected such that every okay
the number of races could be limited to
one federal one state and one county
race for each polling place the
designated races
would be randomly selected such that
every race is verified in at least one
polling place again i believe this bill
is a good start and a companion to a
local public post-election hand count
verification by local election officials
i'll be happy to answer any questions
and we'll send a copy of my full
testimony to the clerk thank you for
your written testimony that would be
terrific that was nearly dead on two
minutes so that was a pretty
impressiveness till does anybody have
any questions for miss till
i'm seeing none in the committee room
anybody attending electronically
i'm not seeing any so thank you miss
till and we look forward to the written
testimony
um
i have
a representative gay signed has
requested to speak on this bill
representative gay you've been promoted
you have two minutes
hi
i don't you all don't even have to
promote me if you just let me speak for
my man a minute i'll be happy um i i'm
calling in because i really want to
offer my support for this bill after
this the nightmare across the nation
from this last election i think we could
set a standard in new hampshire for care
in documenting and making sure things
are verified so this is really
this i'm just very happy to hear so many
bills that are so well thought out and
we know we have lots of people who offer
to do recounts but i would want to make
sure that all the recounts that are done
are done with the same care that the
secretary of state's office has always
done with multiple people watching of
multiple parties uh so that there's
nobody walking out and say they cheated
you know they'll they're there so i
really appreciate this so otp thank you
any questions for representative day
i'm not seeing any so thank you for
coming
i also appear to have a telephone that
says plymouth town hall
and
so uh
i believe that i don't i forget exactly
what you've hit when you're on the phone
to unmute i think it might be star six
um i have promoted you and
if you'd like to speak please join us
okay i apologize for that um i'm at work
this is representative juliette harvey
bolia i represent tilton and samberton
and i just wanted to speak briefly on
the bill good morning and thank you for
the opportunity to address the committee
as lawmakers i believe it is our mission
now more than ever to strengthen
democracy for all our voters by
promoting transparency in our elections
not only is election cyber security
important in every state but as a first
in the nation primary state new
hampshire is a top tier target for
election fraud
one way to promote the responsible use
of technology which introduces risk
election risk
is the implementation of audits to
counter that risk
i ask the committee to vote ought to
pass on house bill 524 which requires
the secretary of state to conduct random
verification counts of polling place
results
i was alarmed when i learned that we do
not have a system of audits in new
hampshire
with informed voters in mind i launched
a website entitled the new hampshire
election integrity project
at nh elections dot us to provide voters
with information about our voting
machines and transparency issues
i raise this issue not to promote the
website but to emphasize that election
and integrity should be a new hampshire
state project
at this point
i researched audits in other states and
found to my surprise that new hampshire
is one of the few states with no audits
in place
even massachusetts conducts audits
one argument against the audits was that
recounts happen anyway post-election as
candidates contest results
that may be so but i asked the committee
when a recount of federal election
candidates has last taken place
risk limiting audits such as this one
are a common tool used by many other
states to mitigate risk
i have faith that the election law
committee will do the right thing
and i'd like to thank representative
lang for writing this bill and as i said
this is not plymouth town hall
uh but representative harvey boglia i
apologize i'm i'm at work
thank you thank you very much for your
testimony another one nearly
two minutes it's getting pretty
impressive here um does anybody have any
questions for the representative
here in the committee room or attending
online
i'm seeing none so thank you very much
for joining us this morning
um also
with a hand raised to speak to this it
is a richard kantos you have been
promoted to a panelist and if you unmute
you're welcome to join us for two
minutes but
if you can identify yourself for us
that'll be great we're all set it looks
like you're ready to go
i'm looking for somebody signing in from
a computer from richard tantos and if
they could unmute
[Music]
we're having a little technical
difficulty i think here
hello this is richard crom place can you
hear me you can thank you welcome
hey just a quick couple quick comments
you know i'm a winter new hampshire
resident and i've been following what's
going on here very closely and i you
know with all due respect to this
secretary of state's office i don't
think they're in touch with what's
currently going on in new hampshire
voter confidence is extremely low and i
think there's a crisis right now of low
voter confidence in new hampshire and i
think you know what may have been an
excuse in the past just doesn't count
anymore i think that now we need to
support all of these bills that point
towards more intelligent election
integrity
in the state of new hampshire
and that's all i have to say
thank you very much any questions for mr
quantos
a panelist attending in person
or online
um also signed up to speak on this is
jeff all of me um and i'm just going to
remind people if if they're
here to
let us know they support the bill they
can sign up and for everybody's
information in regards to this bill
we had 121 people sign up to support
opposing
um
so
thank you people for signing up online
and
uh i think if we if
mr
you can join us as a panelist and speak
and you have two minutes welcome
yes thank you madam chair and members of
the committee this is uh former
representative jeff oligney and no
worries on the last name um i know it's
easy to pronounce and you did better
than most um i'll speak very briefly in
support of the bill and the premier
previous representatives comments about
ongoing random audits
my career about 35 years and and going
is as an engineer particularly
mechanical engineer
very deep into manufacturing quality and
program management and a real quick
story
of something that happened in 1950-ish
was a doctor by the name of j edward
deming and he was a statistician and he
tried to teach the americans how to make
sure that their manufacturing processes
were in control and yielding the desired
results
unfortunately the americans were too
proud and had too much ego to listen to
him so he went to japan
this is the time when
i don't know if you're if you're old
enough like me to recall
the uh the cars made by honda
were junk
um
they and however after dr deming got a
hold of the japanese manufacturing
executives and after a number of years
he implemented these random audits and
process control measures to make sure
that they're yielding the proper results
from their efforts
and as you know as you well know today
uh honda is one of the highest quality
most most desirable vehicles that you
can buy
but the point of the story is that
despite uh how we might think we know
better uh the the statistics don't lie
and there are experts in this field and
i named one dr deming who
dramatically improved the performance of
an entire nation
japan and um and
a brand obviously of the honda
automobile brand
through their use of random audits if
you are not continuously monitoring your
process
for
performance in this case random audits
is the way to do it
then you really don't know how well
you're performing and like likewise i'll
end with this i don't think we really
know how big a problem voter fraud is or
election integrity is unless we have
some real-time ongoing and that means
forever
um ongoing random audits they don't have
to be we don't audit every every polling
place but we pick them at random and
again the statistics don't lie anomalies
will come forward and that will give us
an opportunity to improve performance
and correct some causes of anomalies so
that's it for me thanks for entertaining
me and uh i highly support the bill um
best to you all
[Music]
thank you
um
does anybody have any questions for mr
olympia
all right at this time i'm going to ask
everybody in attendance to raise their
hand because i'm going to close off
public comment if your hand is not
raised at this point
for house bill 524 you will not be
recognized i have one person raising
their hand or someone who signed up
um previously and i have a mr todd you
each have two minutes to speak to this
bill mr o'brien welcome to our panel
welcome back
um
and you are with us if you want you
you have two minutes but we are on 5 24
regarding random verification counts of
fully placed results
mr brian if you can unmute
apologies manager my computer cut out
for a moment um thank you madam chair
members of the committee my name is
michael o'brien i'm here i a lobbyist
with pretty strategies and representing
uh america votes here today i'm here in
support of the audit bill we have seen
um audit bills in front of this
committee in the past and do believe um
that they are a good check um
on elections i will say for this bill in
particular just to um to get into it a
little bit um
i would encourage the committee i've
spent some time talking with some folks
who are experts around audits in
preparation of this bill um i do think
there are some ways uh five locations is
probably not enough to get a statistical
um real cystic field for uh for the
state so i'm not sure we need to audit
every
one but examining how many uh would be
good
um
second requiring a full hand recount of
every ballot is not necessarily the most
efficient way to conduct an audit it can
be done more efficiently and reach the
same level of confidence about the
outcome by randomly selecting sample
ballots from all the balance casts this
will both save time um certainly in the
process but
is is a good way and sort of a more
productive way to do that i would
encourage uh everyone to interested in
this to look at some research done by
the democracy fund i think they do a
good job uh summarizing the audits and
and lastly and quickly i'll just say
we hear a lot about voter fraud and the
statistics of people who believe that
fraud is real um we just went through a
really divisive election in which fraud
was mentioned every day on our
television screens um for at least six
months um if not more than that it's not
surprising that people believe that
fraud is real based just on what they
see and what they hear regardless of how
much truth or not truth there is to
those
accusations so i think as we look at
things that can help increase uh
people's belief in the system we should
be doing that knowing in the background
that we also need to be very much aware
of what our words are and what we say
because they do impact people's faith as
well
that's all i'll say thank you madam
chair have to take any questions if any
committee members have them thank you mr
o'brien for being with this morning any
questions from committee members in our
committee room
come back from anybody online
all right i'm going to recognize the
last speaker on this bill that would be
mr todd
you will be able to join us
uh yes good morning can you hear me we
can welcome two minutes
yeah thank you i just wanted to uh reach
out and say that i supported this bill i
support absolutely support this bill and
i wanted to tie in quickly with what
jeff oligney had said i too am a
mechanical engineer and i um i did take
a manufacturing class and do wicked work
in the manufacturing field as an
engineer and uh one of the one of the
stories that we learned during our
manufacturing courses is that uh this
story of this uh statistician that left
america to go to japan and really
revolutionize their manufacturing
practices in japan and that is a hundred
percent a true story
and um i mentioned that because i wanted
to show my support in in this and i also
wanted to uh just take a little bit of
my experience in the manufacturing field
and say that mr alignee is absolutely
correct we are constantly bouncing our
processes off of our prints and making
sure that we are yielding the correct
results and uh this is a i 100 support a
random audit and that audit should be
bouncing our results off of what we said
should be happening right how we're
running it and what the uh and what the
results are making sure we're yielding
the correct results and that's all i had
to say i'd like you to use the
opportunity to improve
our election process and to restore
confidence in our election i'm not sure
it's just speaking i've just muted you
i'm not quite sure how you've ended up
as a panelist i don't understand
technology so i apologize but
um
i don't have
anybody in front of me thank you very
much mr todd for your
comments
as the last speaker on this build does
anybody have any questions for mr todd
who i can bring back if you do i think
i'd like to leave
or take them off the panels they have
any questions
okay i'm not saying so i'm going to
close the public hearing on house bill
um
this bill as i said had a significant
amount of people signed up in support
um
and
i just will we have a number of people
attending um i believe you can sign in
your position on this bill later today
and i welcome
you to do that along with continuing to
submit written testimony
uh bill material on bills is
uh received right up until the house
committee exact set and that is votes on
it and
uh we won't be voting on 524 today or
our next bill so
please submit your written testimony
i am going to open the public hearing on
sb 43.
um sb 43 is a matter of some interest i
apologize to everybody for how far
behind we are this morning is my worst
job at scheduling all year
i apologize we have not been this late
at any other time
um
sb 43 is here from the senate
um it is a bill authorizing and audit of
the rockingham county district 7 state
representative
race
you have heard
testimony in the previous bill
in regards to issues regarding audits
and elections
and i understand that senator gray
should be with us
to introduce this bill
and senator gray if you can
raise your hand
um
you will find i will watch senator gray
senator gray you are with us this
morning good morning i can see you and
if you unmute we i think we'll be all
set to go on sb
43. uh thank you madam chairman and
thank you to the rest of the committee
uh i am james gray i'm the senator from
district six
i'm also the chairman of the senate
election law committee uh here to
present to you senate bill 43
authorizing an audit of the rockingham
county
uh district 7 state representative race
uh certainly the senate
rules are a little more liberal than the
house rules
so we were able to take a bill
that was on a different subject
replace it with the language that you
see in front of you
and it did pass the senate uh with a
unanimous vote 24 to nothing
we take this issue very seriously
we understand that after
our action and the bill has come to you
that there are a couple of things
that your committee and
the members
would like to see some modification
those that come after me uh we'll talk
about those things and i heartily
endorse the uh the bill you're about to
hear
thank you senator gray
um
senator gray uh
are you willing to take any questions i
understand that the
sort of the major parties involved in
this
uh might have come to some sort of
agreement as to how to proceed under the
overlay of your sb 43
and
with the committee's permission
because those individuals are going to
talk about what has occurred as far as i
understand i'm going to reserve
questions for senator gray um until
after we hear from some of the people
who have been active in this matter they
have signed up to speak
um and
we'll sort of
see what we need to go back to
i want to thank senator greg for being
with us all morning and again i
apologize for the late start it is my
intent to try to go on this for another
hour before taking a short recess
um when we take that short recess we
will see where we are as far as
testimony and what we want to do to
proceed
uh for members of the public and
committee members we do have executive
sessions scheduled today
and it is my open intent that given i
understand there seems to be a consensus
and agreement as to how to proceed with
these issues raised by the wind and
voting results that we will indeed be
able to get our business done because
there are a number of people who have
done a lot of hard work
in regards to this bill
so
having said that
um i would like to recognize
actually the first person who signed up
to speak on this bill who is ken eyring
mr eyring if you are online
i see you are if you can raise your hand
or if you're already aligned
this is dave scanlon uh my name is going
to appear
there's three of us in in the secretary
of state's office that uh may testify on
this starting with ken ering so he's
going to be in the box that has my name
on it
thank you very much deputy stanley for
bringing that to our attention uh mr
eyring
welcome to the election law committee
you've signed up to speak on this bill
and we look forward to hearing from you
great thank you very much i've been
asked to speak uh
on behalf of a lot of people who are
concerned about this issue and i
appreciate the opportunity madam
chairman
uh for speaking i just before i get into
this i want to thank senator gaida for
all the work that he's done
it's
it's unbelievable how much time and
effort he's put into this
this concern
and finding a solution to it over the
past couple of months
everybody wants to make sure that our
elections
mean something that our votes count and
i think without the work of senator
gaida we wouldn't be here today
i also want to thank
secretary of state gardner
i reached out to him
on my own yesterday
realizing that when me
when the hearing happened today that
there might be a lot of people that
wanted to speak that there might be
different
consensus as to which way to move
forward and it was my concern that maybe
maybe
this
solution might get derailed so i reached
out to the secretary
to see what his concerns were and to
share mine
and i was very surprised and pleased
that
we spoke for about three hours and we we
literally just had a conversation and it
was very cordial
and it was very uh heartwarming
to hear and to understand that
his his major concern was that he did
not want to
create a precedent that would be carried
forward where a recount of a recount
took place
and and after talking about that we
go to address some of the issues that
were of concern
and i believe we found
a process that addresses
all of my concerns and all the concerns
that i've heard from others
and so i'd like to just go through that
so that everybody can understand where
we're at and i'm very pleased that
chairman griffin is on board and that
all the uh all the other people
involved
to this point of my knowledge are
completely on board
so before i get into that though i also
want to acknowledge dr dave strang he
spent an awful lot of time with the
senator and myself
and tom murray as well
working
doing the data and just
defining what the concerns are and what
the possible solutions are
so as i said so just a quick recap i'm
sure everybody knows that there was a
huge discrepancy between november 3rd
and november 12th
and you know people are concerned about
different possible reasons for that my
concern has always been we don't know
the answer and in order to get the
answer we need to do a thorough and
complete analysis
and i'm really
happy with the fact that um
you know we've come up with something
it might take a slightly different path
than what others
have have in their minds but i i urge
you to wait until i'm done reading what
we've agreed to and think about it
because like i said i believe this
addresses every issue thoroughly and
completely
so um
you know the bottom line for me is do
wintam's voting machines work properly
and and that's what this is going to
address
so from there i want to read
uh oh no i also want to include uh the
fact and a thank you out to uh chairman
ross mcleod of the winning board of
selectmen i met with him about a month
ago expressed my concerns got him on
board
and he's been uh he's he's been
wonderful we had a meeting
uh last monday to discuss
this issue
and uh this all the entire select board
was in complete agreement and there were
people there who shared their thoughts
and even the vendor who takes care of
our machines and one of our moderators
we're in complete support of a full
forensic audit on our machines and
ballots so
this is an issue where everybody's on
board and and i'm really glad that we're
here so i'm going to read through what
we've agreed to
[Music]
and then i'll come back and i'll just
give a couple thoughts uh as to what
this is and then
i think everybody will have a good
understanding and hopefully feel good
about this
so there's three three items here the
first one is all four of the windham new
hampshire accuvote voting machines and
ballots will be analyzed by a team of
forensic analysts
one forensic analyst will be chosen from
each of the two groups below to perform
a full forensic analysis
group a and the secretary will pick the
person from this group this
includes harry hirsty ron rivest
and andrew appel
these are people that the secretary has
worked with in the past and he feels
very comfortable with i'm actually
familiar with the first name on the list
and
and i trust that the secretary's
analysis of the others are also very
accurate
and the secretary has graciously allowed
me to pick the name from the second list
and on that is colonel phil waldron and
dr shiva ayadure
and they will work together in addition
there'll be a third person working on
the team and that is jovan hutton
pulitzer
who will also be a member of the
forensic team
the forensic analysts will determine in
their own discretion the process that
will be followed
for the forensic analysis so this is an
independent forensic analysis
the new hampshire secretary of state and
the town of windham will provide the
forensic analysts with whatever
resources
the analysts need necessary to perform a
complete and thorough forensic analysis
including but not limited to
full access to the accuvote machines
and all of the ballots from the windham
new hampshire november 3rd 2020 election
i want to point out
that i'm going to deviate from the
script just a little bit i want to point
out that the machines will remain in the
custody of the windham town officials
audit will take place
in a location other than windham where
the customary recount locations
for the secretary of state
right now what's being proposed is the
police standards and training facility
in concord because it's set up to handle
a process of this size and there's a lot
of cameras
that can be made available to
ensure the integrity and the
transparency of the process which is
utmost importance to all of us
the forensic team will produce a report
of their findings and present to the
secretary of state
who will make it available to the public
forthwith
number two all of the windham new
hampshire ballots from the november 3
2020 election will be tallied through
each of windham's four accuvote machines
the paper tapes from all four machines
will show the results for all races
be compared with each other
and be included with in the forensic
report
number three
a hand count by the secretary of state's
office will be performed on two races
other than the rockingham county
district 7 state rep race
so
some people might think that we need to
do another recount on that rate so
that's it that's that's what we've
agreed to and i just want to provide
just a couple comments
to allay what what people might think
we're overlooking
by not doing a second recount on the
district 7 state rep race we've met the
concerns of secretary of state gardner
and
i believe that whatever answers are not
provided with that particular race not
being recounted
we're still going to have a recount by
the secretary of state's office which
can then be compared with the results
from the four hacky vote machines and
all of those paper tape ballots will be
made available so we can compare them
ourselves
in addition to that we are going to have
a full forensic
audit and analysis of all the ballots
and all the machines
so
the people involved there
are
that i've spoken to so far i've spoken
to three people but um colonel waldron i
spoke with this morning he's he's
available he can he can perform this
audit within the next 45 days as will be
mandated by this bill
i've been in contact with joe von hutton
bulwitzer uh he's a paper guy he's the
ballot guy so
from my perspective
this is covered
with
experts with
impeccable
and unquestionable qualifications in
order to perform
what we've been seeking all along and
that's simply do our
voting machines work properly
we've also been
assured that
concerned citizens like myself senator
gaida dr dave strang
wyndham residents tom murray uh and
christy saint-laurent people that she
feels comfortable with will be
given
the ability the ability to be present up
close
uh to provide uh for observations where
we can
confidently relay
that this is a completely and
transparent process
and that and also thorough
so um
i think with that
i'm done
i'm very happy and very grateful again
to us the secretary of state
for his taking my call and for us
talking last night i was i was really
i was really pleased with uh with the
essence of who he is and i'm i'm quite
grateful for the solution that we've
come up with i believe that
we're going to
do whatever is possible to find out as
much as we can
regarding what happened with our
machines on november 3rd so thank you
chairman griffin for allowing me to
speak
thank you very much mr eyring for your
testimony here this morning and your
work on this issue more than happened
with windham in the state
um is are there any members of the
committee who have a question for mr
eyring
anybody online
was that a hand representative lane
thank you
go ahead i did meet on you thanks
we can't hear you
um we're having trouble hearing
representative lane you're showing up as
not being unmuted try again
all right
not coming through
can she call in on the phone
well representative gay thank you if you
could be muted please representative
wayne will have i.t
all right
um
we'll work on that i'm not quite sure
why
people are coming through
it shouldn't be all right does anybody
else on the committee have a question
for mr ring and when we get i don't
think mr iron is going anywhere so if we
figure it out we can go back to
representative lane representative ryan
yeah
go ahead
i'm can you hear me now
everything's fine okay all right so i i
i put in my headsets i don't know what i
did but um
and i'm sorry um
i i came in just a few minutes late and
i'm i'm just is this a bill that is
being proposed to us and have we
received copies of it or is this
we're not going to have a hearing on the
bills and the amendments
you representative lane for your
question if you look at the bill for sb
uh 43 and it's one of the reasons that
senator gray is still online i hope
um there is sort of um a general
overview and this has certainly gotten
much more specific as to what's going to
be done
um there has not been a specific
amendment worked out
um there was some question between
people as to whether the amendment the
bill
sb 43 as we have it
um is sufficient to cover everything
that has been agreed
it is my suspicion that the committee
after hearing from people will think
that an amendment to address the
specifics of what is being proposed is
probably appropriate
and that uh something else will be done
for the committee for its deliberation
but given the the
issues
there were some people thought that sb
43 in its current form before the
committee would be sufficient
um to cover what we're talking about
today so i think the committee will need
to have some discussion as to whether an
amendment is appropriate after we hear
everything
adam chairman i interject briefly that
there was an amendment that was
circulated to all the committee members
last night at 7 00 p.m there are a
number of amendments that have been
circulated to committee members and none
of them have been generated in
accordance with what we're talking about
this morning okay that is my
understanding
um we have amendments from and senator
guy will be hearing from this morning
um we have some something that's been
proposed by a representative from
windham
uh there have been a number of
amendments forwarded to committee
members so
um at this point talking about the bill
which is before us sb 43
and what has been agreed
okay
thank you madam chair and i apologize
for having missed the first few minutes
i i do have a question could i do a
follow-up sure
um
i did hear that the the goal was do
windham's machines work
properly
is there
and i understand the focus is on the
machines but what if the machines are
fine but we still have this discrepancy
is that addressed and what you laid out
oh wait if mr ellering i'm gonna allow
you to address the answer to that
question
okay well it's my thought and it's my
belief that if we
allow these forensic analysts to come in
that they'll they'll do a thorough job
and they'll find whatever
information and details they can just to
give you
a reference of who the people that i've
recommended to be a part of this process
are colonel phil waldron and
johann hutton pulitzer colonel phil
waldron has been involved with the
forensic analysts analysis of antrim
county michigan also in georgia and also
he's out in arizona right now he's got a
team of 10 people working 50 days to
analyze 2.1 million ballots
and
and in addition to that
joe joe vaughan hutton pulitzer he's a
paper guy
but he's all he's a brilliant man
he has over 200
patents regarding barcode technology
and when you take your phone and you
scan a barcode and the product comes up
that's his technology it's used on over
12 billion devices in the world
he has the ability to
he has a team as well and he's worked
very closely with colonel waldron
he was in it he was in uh georgia
the
friday before the
runoff election for the senate
and uh he was testifying in their senate
hearing committee about elections and
while that hearing was going on his team
broke in
to one of the polling places
live
and saw that saw the voting taking place
in real time and also with data packets
being transmitted over to china and back
and
and he reported that to the committee so
these people have impeccable
knowledge of the equipment of the
technology standpoint they're going to
look at the machines they're going to
check the scanners
they'll check the programs on the
machines they'll compare them across
each machine
and
and they'll also look at the ballots
they're going to scan the ballots with a
third-party device
and and
that'll be a cross-reference to make
sure that the results uh came back
accurately with the machines that we use
in all of our elections and at that
point we're going to eliminate uh the
ballots and the technology and if the
questions haven't been answered then
it'll be up to the secretary of state's
office to try to and and our town
election officials to try to figure out
where the issue occurred but you know
for my concern and i think from the
concern of many people in the public is
we just want to make sure that our votes
as they're being tabulated by machines
are accurately calculated and totaled so
at the end of the day we know who won so
that the people that we're voting for
actually represent us in office
thank you very much
thank you too
representative cody
yes ma'am chad i i guess i'm trying to
figure out what in what context the
gentleman's remarks are taking place we
have the bill before us we have several
amendments
uh could he help me with that
no he probably couldn't i don't know
that he has seen all the amendments some
of what is being
there are people who believe that
nothing needs to be amended in sb 43 to
proceed as it is
so
it is my hope that given the issue the
importance and the agreement
that the committee is able to attend to
what representatives who are directly
involved in this process or would be
have to say about the process that
senator ray who is here from the senate
indicates that
either there is a further amendment that
he thinks it's appropriate or this
committee thinks is appropriate um i
understand it is confusing to have a
number of amendments down and if
somebody wants to speak to their
amendment as we proceed
um i think we can do that but i
apologize for the confusion but uh given
the circumstances
this committee will do the best it can
i excuse me manchester i wasn't asking
his opinion of the amendments i was
asking for the content context of his
discussion
in other words
how does his proposal fit into what we
are supposed to do
with this bill
i think that's up to our committee to
decide i think there was concern about
getting something on the record as to
what actually
is going to occur
and
i think our committee has the option of
drafting an amendment with the specifics
if it feels necessary
i guess i'm trying to figure out whose
auspices these discussions took place
and who was involved with them
thank you
okay thank you
i thought uh mr eyring said who he had
spoken to but
uh perhaps not representative
question of the chairman
yeah yeah so
what we heard was aaron discussed in the
agreement that uh
and set forth
just want to clarify that is that is
separate from the hearing on this bill
in essence am i understanding that
correctly or not
i think what we're hearing is what's
being proposed as the
as the remedy to be performed whether it
is directly as a result of sb 43 as it
stands in words now or whether it is
amended
representative bergeron
thank you ma'am chairman i wonder if we
could just ask the previous speaker to
submit in writing the summary that he
read or
stated to us so that we have a better
understanding about the details for
example i heard
frequent references to machines but does
that include the memory cards that are
used in those machines will it be an
analysis done to those uh so in short if
if he could give us a summary of a
written summary what he discussed that
would be very helpful
i'm sure that will be possible i do
think some of the specificity that i
know committee members like to
see
um i would submit i that many of the
people involved in this are sort of
leaving the details to the forensic
audit team given their standing because
um i think there's some concern if we
get into too many specifics in regards
to what's going on
um if we miss something then it becomes
an issue
but i think i saw mr l green nodding his
head
are there other
yes if i just may interject it is a
complete and thorough analysis of the
machines and their memory cards
and the flash memory
as well which holds the program for the
machines
thank you so we'll get that dude in
writing thank you thank you
is there anybody else on the committee
with the question for mr elring
oh i'm sorry
thank you madam chair
uh mike i i was at the meeting in
windham on monday evening
when the community discussed this issue
and
i saw
that you were definitely a community
leader
that many people in the room the
hundreds of people in the room were
were looking to
for some answers guidance and direction
and then
that at that meeting when it when it
ended there was a very quick committee
that was created to discuss this issue
far further and that committee
was made up of
i believe yourself but members of the
windham um select board
and then they were going to come up with
recommendations and some ideas of how to
best solve this problem
are you a representative of that
committee
and that and and do you come here today
with the
uh
the
the recommendations that that committee
in windham has come up with
is that what this is
for clarification thank you
i'm here as a windham resident
i'm not authorized to be here by the any
member of the windham town government
i took it upon myself yesterday out of
concerns that
i knew how important this bill is and i
wanted to reach out to the secretary of
state to express my thoughts
and to see if he could help guide
through the process some of the concerns
that i had
i was served on that committee the
committee put out a bullet point of i
believe 11 items
i don't have that list in front of me
but apparently i believe you guys have
received it
from what i've heard last night at 7
o'clock
and i believe to the best of my
knowledge thinking off the top of my
head that all of the issues on that are
covered and then some so
i i think that all of windham's
interests as expressed by the committee
that was put together by the board of
selectmen are being addressed and i
believe you'll hear from some other
people from our town as well
in a little while
further questions from panelists
all right
thank you mr ellering at this time
secretary of state william gardner
in regards to
issues surrounding the window
and sb 43 which is before us as
authorizing an audit
to respond to questions for the winning
audit welcome secretary gardner
thank you madam chair
members of the committee
i'm especially pleased to support
this plan that ken eyring of windham has
put together
it emanates from the action of the state
senate when they voted unanimously about
two weeks ago
this is
in the best interest
of the people of windham
and
and of all the people of new hampshire
what the senate
uh did with senate bill 43
was
sort of a a roadmap a
framework and
some
people have been
interested in sort of fleshing out
uh
how this
would be done
and
what
can iring have presented to you
is
that
that's what it is
thank you secretary gardner
questions for secretary gardner
representatives roseanne thank you madam
chair thank you
mr secretary
secretary for taking my question
so i'm assuming to do this audit it's
going to take some some time to complete
and
i believe that donald windham has a
election coming up
next week
so do they have other memory cards that
will be used on that
town election so that the memory cards
in question that are going to be
assuming looking at technically
not
pretty nervous about that
thank you
yes every everything
is protected everything
related to the machines
uh
are in windom
other questions from panelists
they're going to use different machines
representative
ryan thank you man
are they using different machines for
the march election and windham
are they used to different electronic
ballot counting machines
yes
different ones
other questions from committee members
representative barry
audience the do uh does your office have
a
idea of what happened here at all we
have any sort of clue
or is this we're in the dark we need
this bill to try to figure out what
happened we have any idea
no unfortunately i
i do not
we had
no i i i don't i was going to today
talk about
the recounts that we've done
uh
that
you know because there's been a lot of
chatter about
was this the biggest discrepancy ever or
anomaly ever and
and the answer is no
and were there many recounts that had
percentages higher than this yes
in the past if you go back
and
so but it it
it obviously has
generated a lot of concern
and interest
and
uh the hope is that
we'll have some answers
uh
it's
some sometimes it's hard
to get the answers
and
this is going to be an attempt
to actually accomplish that
further questions for secretary gardner
representative rowan secretary gardner
um
from your testimony just just
reaffirming you fully support this plan
and we'll be able to implement this plan
if this is what we decide to pursue
yes
thank you
any other questions from committee
members for secretary gardner
thank you madam chairman thank you
to christy governor taking my question
if we follow the plan that was just
described to us by mr airing
and if
this
focus on the voting machines indicates
that the voting machines function
properly
will we have gained any insight into
why the 300 roughly 300 vote discrepancy
occurred in those state rep
recounts
it seems to me that
machines work properly then there is
still more investigation to be done to
determine the exact cause of the
discrepancy
the rockingham center recounts so will i
know
what caused that
at the end of this investigation
well i certainly
hope that we will
that's uh
and i think that this
is
the best
and appropriate way
to get there
thank you for the follow-up madam
chairman uh
i noted the plan is describing me for
which i've not yet seen any
documentation that it says there'll be
no second recount of uh rockingham seven
if i understood that correctly so if the
machines are shown
have worked properly i'm not sure how i
would get the answer to what exactly
happened in rocket games
i'd like to understand that better
please
thank you
well this
uh
is
not called in the bill that you have
uh
a second recount
it's
called
an audit
and
the process that
can i ring
as explained to you
hopefully is the way
uh
that
everyone
will
get the answers that they're
of the questions that they've been
asking
further questions from the committee for
the secretary
representative
bryant thank you ma'am
and thank you mr governor secretary
general for answering our questions
the
the attorney general's office is
looking over what happened
in this election will that continue
in concert with what is happening here
and
are you
and then i have a follow-up thank you
yes
uh
follow-up
thank you uh
does this set any precedence
that
concerns you moving forward for
at all
this is this is new um and how do you
and how do you what's your opinion on on
the newness of this and precedent
well uh
there have been
[Music]
multiple recounts
in the past that
have had
percentage of difference
between
the winner and the loser and changes
that occurred at the recount that
have been
greater than this one
uh
and
but this
difference
that the
one
only one candidate
of eight
on the ballot for state representative
lost votes in this recount only one
every other candidate three of the
democrats and four of the republicans
all gained votes
and
that in combination
with
the increase
uh number of
votes that we found at the recount
makes it a little bit
it makes it unique
in a small way but but it does make it
unique and
uh
there's
a lot of concern about it and
a lot of people feel really strongly
about it and
you know you listen to the debate about
the audit bill you you've just had
and
this
uh
this meme that they had in wyndham
a really
a lot of credit to ken eyring for
talking about it bringing it
some of the things that uh
were known down there but might not have
been known known in other parts of the
state
and
so
it's
i think this is the appropriate way and
it's a good way to do it and it's a way
that
hopefully we're going to end up with
answers sometimes you just can't
get
a definitive answer
thank you secretary gardner further
questions for secretary gardner
representative barry uh yes
secretary gardner um
does your office
understand that there are a large
percent of the voting electorate that
are skeptical of our elections the way
we conduct them and do you believe that
this audit
would help alleviate some of those fears
and concerns which i believe are very
legitimate
yes i would
all right representative
thank you madam chair thank you
secretary gardner for taking the
question
is it safe to say that if um the
candidate in windham had asked for
recount had not asked the recount we
would admit never have known of any
potential anomalies in that
election
i'm going to ask for clarification
as to what you need for
trojan anomalies
there's been significant discussion in
the public sphere as to anomalies but
those had to do with the machine council
had nothing to do with free counseling
let me rephrase the question then
the reason
and maybe i'm wrong in this i'm trying
to get clarification
um
if the candidate
that asked for recount
the state rep candidate in windham had
never asked for a recount
it's safe to say we would never been
aware of any
particular
i'm using it normally because that's
what we're calling it but
um
[Music]
potentially yeah go
ahead you know a potential problem with
the results in other words
i understand if we had if they hadn't
asked for recount we would have never
known there was a problem there maybe
that's a better way to ask it
well i would
think that
nothing would happen
and uh
because in this case the winner
i mean the most first of all
what's first and foremost
is that we make sure that every person
who serves an elected office
was the duly elected person for that
office
and i can
unequivocally say that
in my years
every person who has served has been the
person
who got the most votes
and
in a case where you have a recount and
the winner on election night is also the
winner after the
recount
those instances
usually
just end right there
i can add that
if you go back to 2000 yeah i've done
just about 600 recounts over the years
so i've seen
i've i've
overseen 11 recounts that ended in a tie
vote
i've overseen 32 recounts that ended in
a person winning by one
vote
over 200 of them were single because
recounts tend to be
close
but there has been
an example of what you're
asking about
in 2008
we had a recount in windham
for a state representative race
in a primary
that a candidate
received 430 votes
on election night
and after the recount the candidate had
621 votes
that was
191 votes that is far greater
difference than this particular recount
but
it was a
multi-candidate
race and the person was
if the person didn't
get those additional votes the person
still would have
uh one
so it depends on the situation that
uh
you know
when you have
the number of human beings that we have
involved in our
elections we have over 6 000
people at the local level
humans as we know can make a
mathematical error there can be a human
error here or there
not that it's deliberate
but it happens
and
you can't get
perfection
but what you want for perfection is that
the right person
actually was able to win the nomination
and be on the ballot in november or win
the election
and serve
in office after
thank you secretary gardner further
questions for secretary gardner
i'm not saying any thank you for joining
us this morning um also signed up to
speak and joining us this morning is
senator gaia
senator gaia i believe
you're all set to join us this morning
good morning
thank you madam chairman and um members
of the committee
um we meet today to reaffirm the
integrity of our elections it's that
simple
the chronology and the extant facts that
brought us here are well documented and
public they don't require repeating
one race in one community produced a
significant vote count disparity
captured during a subsequent recount
that disparity would not have been
discovered without that recount why is
it important
to find out the cause because 85 percent
of the towns and cities in this state
use the accuvolt machine which produced
it
our citizens as i'm sure you well know
are demanding to know and we're bound by
our shared commitment to the sanctity of
our elections to ensure
that the machines and the process by
which our citizens elect us and shape
our future can be trusted
we meet today because at least existing
law was interpreted to deny the state's
obligation to investigate what caused
this very large and as yet unexplained
shift in votes between the machine count
and the subsequent hand recount in the
windham district 7 election
our assembly here today
is an affirmation that our citizen
legislature understands the critical
importance of the sanctity of every
ballot cast in every election it's an
affirmation that we understand the
critical importance of public trust in
our elections
and it's an affirmation that our
citizens armed with facts and driven by
a thirst for truth can trust us to
ascertain that truth
i'm compelled to speak of the
extraordinary efforts of dr david strang
and what i consider to be nothing less
than the heroic efforts of citizen ken
eyring of windham
to move this issue forward to the point
that it needs to be and that is right
here in front of you to make that
determination
we seek a way forward that will sustain
our faith in elections by addressing the
windham vote count disparity that way
forward has been suggested
by ken eyring and endorsed by secretary
gardner please remember that we you and
i
have four decades now elected bill
gardner to be our secretary of state
because of his unswerving dedication to
the duties of his office
since my first term in the house 20
years ago
i've watched him without prejudice and
without hesitation jealously guard the
sanctity of every vote and the conduct
of every election in this state
having heard his thoughts on how he
believes we should proceed
i ask you on behalf of the thousands of
our citizens who are asking to adopt the
process secretary gardner has suggested
so we who are the repositors of the
public trust
can completely and truthfully answer the
question
what happened in windham new hampshire
on november 3rd 2020.
i thank you for your your attention and
i would be willing to answer any
questions
thank you very much senator guy for
being with us and having been a part of
this process
do any committee members have questions
for senator gaia
any committee members in the room i i do
madam chair oh sorry representative
burnham choosing looking on my screen
uh it's senator gaida um
would it be your
opinion that the senate
would also support this uh plan that is
that is uh completely supported by
our secretary of
i'm not uh if authorized or qualified to
speak for the other members
i for one would certainly advocate it
it's been the product of work that
involved all the interested parties the
secretary of state the town of windham
the citizen myself
and i think that the senate's passage of
uh senate bill 43 and unanimous vote
indicates the desire to move ahead with
the process and if we can better shape
that process i think that the senate
would support this and i would be
willing to advocate for that
thank you senator
thank you very much other questions for
senator gaia
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
senator for being with us this this
morning thank you very much madam chair
it's an honor to be here
i would like to next rep uh recognize
keith
hardington
hardington he is the vice chair i
believe of the windham board of staff mr
partington
you have been promoted to be a member of
the panel and i think if you are new you
will be with us
hi can you hear me you can good morning
yes thank you good morning yes that is
correct i am the vice chairman of the
windham board of selectmen
um this is a very important issue to our
community and to the board of selectmen
in windham
um to be clear i can't speak on behalf
of the entire board with regard to
anything that has occurred since
wednesday afternoon
um i and i have not seen the proposal uh
that mr uh iron got uh you know uh
discussed in writing
um on on wednesday representative uh
charlie mcmahon uh mr eyring christy st
loren who originally had asked for the
recount
myself and several others were part of a
subcommittee meeting which was a result
of a lengthy meeting last monday evening
where significant public input from the
new hampshire community was heard
that committee outputted amendment
language
which which i believe i think you you
may have received last night it
contained 11 letter points
that was later approved by the board of
selectmen on wednesday
with the goal being to get a definitive
answer as to why the machine count and
the recount tallies differ
whether the issue be the local windham
process something with the windham
machines
or the state recount process
in other words we cannot focus the audit
solely on the machines
now i don't want to derail this process
to derail any movement towards getting a
definitive answer here
but what what mr eyring did after five
hours of meetings on wednesday with the
town was to do an end around on that
process to propose something different
today than what he had agreed to on
wednesday without discussing this with
others that were part of that process
that being said both the members of that
subcommittee and the windham selectmen
knew the language of any amendment
would likely be edited
if the points generally meet or exceed
what was proposed by the subcommittee i
don't see any reason why the windham
board of selectmen would not fully
support such a measure
on the surface the new proposal sounds
more comprehensive
but as i said i have not seen anything
in writing
one thing i am not completely
clear on
is the recount measures
once again because i don't believe this
process should focus solely and only on
the machines
several counts um did not take place
during the the state recount
um that may have given us more clarity
into what happened including the number
of ballots the number of undervotes the
number of overvotes and the blanks
it's crucial in this new process that if
we are to do a recount and we absolutely
i think believe we need to do a recount
that those
additional counts need to occur to give
us more clarity in the differences
between the output of the machines and
what happened at that recount
lastly i just want to make sure i'm not
sure it was mentioned
i just want to make sure that the the
someone
representatives of the windham board of
selectmen are allowed to
up close and personal get a look into
this audit when it does occur i'm not
sure we were listed on the uh original
list
that's all thank you for your time
thank you for joining us here this
morning mr portington does anybody have
any questions for mr carrington
anybody here in the room any panelists
representative bergeron
thank you madam chairman mr partington
um
can if you have already sent those 11
points that the board of selectmen uh
approved uh yesterday or the or recently
i apologize but could you send that to
the house election law committee again
just um
i'm sure he can we should have it i
actually have it in front of us
um and just so
members of the public and people here
can
um
hear what they were they were to
preserve the current state
um that the ballots being detained by
the secretary of state
that the bodies take place in a neutral
location
other than concord or windham
um that
overall ballot inventory verification
shall be performed
at the beginning of the audit process
the window board celebrities ask me to
retain the ability to perform an
independent forensic analysis
um and i i will say i'm not sure that
that is contained in anything
um that they are requesting that the
accounts be hand tally if it starts
taking several county district seven
state representative race um i'm not
sure that that is included and mr ellery
i understand that the secretary of state
are also we said we get into a little
bit of the difference between a recount
and an audit at that point
um 100 of the ballots will be run in
their entirety to evolve forward the
machines
i believe that is part of it
um the audit will be live streamed and
recorded
and then they have some things that they
would like in regards to
who would do it
that the wyndham officials will be
responsible for transporting the ballot
machines to and from the audit on the
days of the audit
um i understand that's part of what
we're talking about
and
that the audit will take place within 45
days of the passage of the bill i
understand that's what we're talking
about
and that there'll be a combination name
for designates from windham to closely
observe the audit in person so if you go
to your email
you should have those provisions
representative wayne
thank you hopefully you can hear me this
time
um
thank you for your testimony i just want
to be clear
do you
did was there a bill that you put
together or were these points that you
wanted in a bill
if i can answer for mr partington
because i'm not sure because he's not
part of the legislature i believe you
received a bill last night
uh which was an amendment to sb43 that
would be the election block he gave me
an email
it was amendment number 2021 638 each
um on this bill where representative
mcmahon griffin saudi and lynn these are
window representatives
um and i believe this was an attempt to
incorporate the 11 things that i just
listed
into
i would concur with that
other questions for for mr partington
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
mr partington for joining us today
you're very welcome thank you
also in attendance and signed up to
speak on this bill
is
dr david strang
um dr strang joins us and
i believe my zoom system is promoting
you to be a panelist and
welcome to the election law committee dr
stratton
anyone knew i think we're all set
thank you chairwoman griffin and
honorable members of the committee my
name is dr david strang i'm an emergency
physician chair of the advisory council
for new hampshire's prescription drug
monitoring program a 21-year resident of
gilmanton have been working very closely
with both senator guida and ken eyring
on this very important matter
i'm encouraged to hear the plan outlined
by mr eyring jointly agreed to by
secretary of state gardner
i firmly believe it is imperative that
we investigate this what secretary of
state gardner told me on december 10th
was the largest discrepancy between
machine and hand counts in the history
of new hampshire elections
when most political contests are decided
by six percent or less we cannot shrug
off this anomaly with well it didn't
change the outcome of the election
we owe it to the citizens of not just
wyndham but of all new hampshire to
explain this vote count anomaly
let us not forget that 85 percent of new
hampshire towns and cities use this same
machine the only one certified for use
by the ballot law commission
this windham anomaly has shaken the
confidence of new hampshire citizens in
these voting machines
we must be assured that those whom we
truly elected are those that now govern
us do any of you want your constituents
questioning your right to occupy occupy
the seat that you are in today
there is nothing more sacred in a
democracy than the sanctity of the vote
if the accuracy of our elections is
questioned if we lose faith in their
outcomes then it will not be long before
our society disintegrates into distrust
and chaos
it is your undeniable duty to compel an
investigation that will explain this
vote total discrepancy
i strongly urge you to adopt secretary
of state gardner suggestions in writing
i thank you in advance for your support
of this bill and any amendments to
strengthen its resolve thank you for
your time and i will be happy to answer
any questions you may have
thank you very much dr strange for
joining us this afternoon does anybody
have any questions
for dr strang
they're in the community room or
attending electronically
i'm not seeing anything again thank you
very much for your
work and participation in this issue
um also
it was that a question from a community
member
thank you all right thank you
um also
here to speak before the committee this
morning is
christie saint-laurent
um miss saint laurent i have promoted
you to join us on this new platform here
this morning and i think if you i'm you
you will be with us
excuse me
question of the chair
i hate to interrupt but i'm having a
very difficult time seeing this
amendment
on my phone and every once in a great
while i have a copy forward yes i would
like a written copy and if anyone else
is having the same problem okay
you hear the testimony this is one of
the problems of doing things by zoom and
remotely in my opinion because we don't
have one
madam chairman just so you know there
are copies of amendment
0638h on the table
thank you
um and so
actually representative wright and you
could help pass those out that would be
great
um
and you all attending by exam should
have them
in
it was 7 pm
you're with us if you want to unmute so
we can hear from you in regards to what
the proposal is for what's going forward
here with regards to the election that
as i understand you were a part
yes yes so um for the committee my name
is christy st laurent and i am the
candidate who requested the recount
um
we just heard from mr eyring and
apparently he must have misspoken
because the
um procedure that he put forward
actually varies from
the um amendment that was generated from
the proposed amendment that was
generated by the windham election
integrity commission committee and
approved by the board of selectmen
and that biggest discrepancy would be um
on line 29 line f
uh all of the counts shall be hand
tallied pertaining to the rockingham
county district 7 state representative
race
so
recounting hand counting any race other
than
the state rep race is not going to give
us the answer in terms of whether or not
the problem lied with the recount
so i strongly object to that and i would
respectfully ask for the ballot law
commission
um
excuse me the election law committee to
take that into consideration
um as selectman heath partington had
stated the concern of many people is to
not point the finger at the machines per
se but find out directly where the
source of the discrepancy came from and
if the source of the discrepancy was
from the recount then we need to be able
to determine that and the way to do that
would be to repeat
the accounting of those ballots now i
would refer you to the amendment sp 43
or excuse me the bill sb 43
on line uh line 11 it says the secretary
of state and attorney general are
authorized to con conduct an audit of
the rockingham county district 7 race
representative race
so that is what we're supposed to be
determining not only is it a problem
with the machines
so
it's also stipulated in this bill that
the um
that this is not a recount in in terms
of establishing who would win a seat
even when i
appealed to the election law committee
uh excuse me the ballot law committee i
get you guys names mixed up i i said
that you know i am more interested in
finding out the cause of this
discrepancy versus trying to challenge
which four people are going from windham
to serve in the house
the the ballot law committee commission
did say that um representative soti is
the fourth place finisher and has been
awarded the seat and is already
representing the town of windham that's
fine with me
what i want is to find out the cause of
the discrepancy whether it's the town
whether it's the machines or whether it
is the recount process
as much as people need to have
confidence that their ballots are
are counted accurately and we need to
have confidence in our elections
as candidates and as voter voters we
need to have confidence in the recount
process that we can appeal to
when the elections are very close
we have a long history of recounts in
new hampshire i've participated in them
before as observers and
most typically by and large they go off
without a hitch they're they're very
very well run
but i i think
bill gardner secretary of state bill
garner mentioned that that he's overseen
six 600 of them i mean it it's
understandable that there could be
mistakes made at once so i think if that
is where the fault lies that we need to
include that in this comprehensive
thorough transparent public audit to
find the problem
so i i would respectfully appeal to the
committee here to keep that in mind um
moving forward
because
to senator guida's point as much as 85
percent of our towns use the accu vote
machines 100 of our towns have the
recourse of a recount in the event of
close elections
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you for joining us this afternoon
and speaking to this issue does anybody
on the piano have any questions from
miss saint laurent
representative barry mr
did you have observers there advocating
on your behalf
i did yes did you have legal counsel
while you were there
no i did not
further questions representative lane
yes thank you madam chair um miss say
lauren did uh the documents that you
mentioned
uh that you were comparing to are those
available have
they been sent to us or provided to us
you could refer to a committee or a
commission
right now
i know and i apologize because i get
your committee mixed up with that
that's okay ballot law commission so
after the recount because obviously the
results were distressing um just in
scale
my only recourse was to go to the ballot
law commission
most typically and and i did provide um
written testimony that that hopefully
you you have um but most commonly what
happens with those is
if it comes down to a couple of votes
and you disagree with how the secretary
of state interprets the intent of the
voter on a couple of ballots the ballot
law commission will examine those in
their determination stands that wasn't
the case in this situation but it was my
only my only recourse
so i did appeal to them they did
establish that it was representative
soti to get the for the fourth seat but
they did call for an investigation from
the attorney general's office
um
thank you may have a follow-up please
another question
yeah um i guess i maybe i misunderstood
you when you were testifying i thought
that you said there was a local windham
group that had put together
something and that it was uh not all
those maybe it's 11 points that
our chairperson read out i just would
like to get a copy of what you were
referring to
right so all of those points are
included in
i have it listed as
senate bill 43 amendment
0638h
right so that amendment came out as a
result of the the winnham election
integrity committee that was established
by the board of selectmen after the
public meeting that was held
um
a few days just a couple days prior uh
where the voting machine person
representative spoke and and a lot of
public input was heard on the town's
concerns with the elect with the
election results and the recount
thank you
further questions from this loren
sorry
i'm not seeing anything from people in
attendance
or attending online so thank you very
much for being with us on this issue
this afternoon
thank you
also signed up to speak on this issue
is
tom murray
mr murray i have promoted you
to a panelist and i believe if you
unmute you will be able to join us this
morning
thank you madam chair
thank you madam chairman uh members of
the committee uh my name is tom murray
i'm a resident of windham new hampshire
um also a member of the subcommittee
that's being referenced
um
i uh for the most part agree um with
both miss saint laurent and mr partation
however i do believe this is a
misunderstanding i just like to describe
that
we did unanimously take a vote on march
3rd just two days ago at that
subcommittee maining it was a 4-0 vote
the
11 bullet points that are being
mentioned are actually
incorporated into the amendment
i think it's important to note that
these were
simply
you know more or less a wish list of
what we
as members of the subcommittee as well
as members of public
and the board of selectmen
were hopeful that the
election committee would um
take into consideration um however i
think there's some misunderstanding
that's going on because i believe that
um everything that most both mr eyring
and uh secretary of state mr gardner
have discussed is actually incorporated
into that those 11 bullet points i have
both of them in front of me i'm very
familiar with both of them um i
understand the uh
the concern that uh saint laurent um
brought up and i share that concern and
however i also believe that to be
um addressed with the forensic audit
that was mentioned now that being the uh
the hand recount
so um my perspective on this is that
um according to the uh
you know as outlined in the testimony of
mr hiring um that that be that that is
incorporated into those concerns and
with that being said i i would uh
support um
the
senate bill 43 as outlined for that
testimony and um
at the same time i'd also just before i
finish i would like to just thank both
mr eyring secretary of state mr gardner
um members of the windham border
selectmen mr st moran um mr geithner and
as well uh mr david uh strength dr david
sharing so thank you
thank you mr murray does anybody have
any questions for mr murray
here in the room
any anybody attending online have any
questions for mr murray
um
next i'm going to
uh recognize secretary gardner has
asked
whether it's secretary gardner deputy
scanlon if you want to join us please
thank you madam chair and members of
community this is actually david scanlan
as i mentioned when we started off
we're all sharing this laptop in
there i see my name just got changed
thank you um i i just wanted to uh you
know try and bring us around full circle
um
you know there are shared concerns uh
about the count in windham
and there is a desire
uh to get to the bottom of uh you know
what occurred
um
you know as
was proposed uh you know with uh you
know with an agreement or an
understanding um you know the focus is
going to be on the machines themselves
uh you know with a thorough forensic uh
audit of them
and then you know a recount of a couple
of the other races uh they're on the
ballot just to
you know confirm that the machines are
working properly
but i think everybody has to remember as
secretary gardner mentioned in his
comments
that
conducting elections
in new hampshire
is
it involves humans and it
involves a lot of them
and as we all know humans can make
mistakes and and that's a regular
occurrence in new hampshire elections
and as secretary gardner mentioned that
is borne out
in the recounts that we see that you
know there are
some
uh
differences between the election account
and the recount that we can determine
were caused by
human error and it might be something as
simple as
uh double double counting uh write-in
votes uh ballots with write-in votes on
them
uh you know after they go through the
machine it's you know um
you know we've seen things like that in
the past they're addition errors can
happen um ballots can be improperly
handled
and those aren't deliberate or malicious
uh it's just it's a mistake that
somebody made
when we conduct a recount and if we were
to do a full recount again
you know it may be more evident where
the issue may have occurred
but we still may never know what
happened and and that's just that's
again the human component of it
i think
what we have done here with the
conversations between secretary gardner
and mr eyring and others is
come to those mutual um
[Music]
areas where you know we want to try and
get as much information as we can to at
least confirm that the machines
were working properly and
you know and if we can do that you know
we may be able to to glean some other
information about you know what happened
in the in the actual physical accounting
part of it
but again we may never know and
um more we understand the better you
know we're hearing
uh testimony on other bills related to
audits uh moving forward those are
certainly appropriate
um
but let's let's try and work together to
uh
you know come up with a process that
will
address the issues that we all believe
are important uh even though in the end
we may not get all the answers uh that
we're looking for
and with that madam chair i'd be happy
to answer any questions
questions from committee members
anybody don't want anybody into anybody
all right i'm not seeing any uh
at this point it is 110
uh the committee is going to take a 30
minute recess this public hearing will
reconvene
in 30 minutes
um at that time i will be
um asking how many people want to
testify in regards to this matter
and i will be determining how much time
will be allocated to each speaker
um he will not be accepting this bill
today or building on it
i remind everybody that we remain
accessible online for comments
and so sb 33 will continue for a certain
amount of time at which point this
committee will then take up the
scheduled consecutive session bills
obviously later than they were
i see our committee assistant the japan
smarling is on screen did you have
something you needed to let us know pam
no i'm just waiting to post your notice
maybe cam would like to leave her office
too so thank you everybody see you in
half an hour
okay
hey
bye
um
okay
[Music]
is
okay
[Music]
um
uh
so give it an inch
[Music]
he said anyways
um
this
okay
oh
madam chair you'll need to unmute the
computer down in the room
um
from the room i can't unmute you from
from here
to can you hear us now
yes i can
there we go do i need to do it do i need
to start the video also or not
yes the video does need to be turned on
all right are we all set you up
i'm gonna fire my tech support which has
left for lunch and not come back ah
that's the problem
we had someone try it and unfortunately
we got something completely foreign on
the screen so we would refund it to
continue
but i finally decided i needed to take
matters into my own hand so my apologies
to everyone
the 30 some odd minute break has turned
into me over 35 almost 40.
so i apologize i want to thank everybody
for continuing to be with us this is we
are resuming the public hearing on sb 43
as
indicated a number of people signed up
in regards to this bill
um we had 45
as i said 415
signed up in support
i believe that sign ups on this pay up
correctly if i'm wrong we'll continue
from tonight and we can continue to
receive
testimony
i have
29 people signed up to speak on this
bill
that does not mean they're all here or
that there aren't other people who want
to speak so
the majority of the people who have
signed up to speak have indicated that
they need two minutes to speak
so
i am going to run through the list of
names that i have signed up
with two minutes to a person
and then i will ask for people who have
not signed up to raise their hand
so we can hear from them on this matter
and the first person i don't um
that signed up to speak on this is
nicole
bataille i i hope that i've pronounced
that correctly
um you are still with us today so thank
you for sticking with us for a long day
and i believe if you unmute yourself we
will be able to hear from you
nicole
yes yes thank you can you hear me
thank you for recording us
okay thank you thanks for having me good
afternoon and thank you election law
house committee for your time and
attention my name is nicole bowtie and
i'm the windham town clerk i am speaking
in favor of proposed amendment given by
board of selectmen for the town of
windham i was also one of the
subcommittee members involved with
drafting this amendment proposal
since the alleged discrepancy my office
has received dozens if not hundreds of
emails calls letters and many right to
know requests from winterham residents
new hampshire residents media etc
everyone especially the town officials
are deeply concerned and rightfully so
there are many theories and speculations
as to what could have happened and to
put these all pressed and have the
warranted closure is paramount
this amendment of bullets will include
more of a local presence so this audit
is accomplished with a collaborative
effort across the board most of these
bullets are basic including preservation
of the ballots and machines in their
current state and control along with the
overall ballot count verification some
of these proposals such as the neutral
location for the audit and all three of
the parties abstaining from conducting
the audit are simply to make sure that
all areas are covered with transparency
and being as unbiased as possible
in order to maintain public trust and
continued transparency through this
delicate situation
i would strongly encourage that this is
handled with the utmost sensitivity
the more concerns that many people have
raised was a response time to this
when this all came to light
there wasn't much action taken but we
all know this wouldn't just go away
especially given the political climate
that we've all been in
we are four months out from the november
general and it seems like we haven't
progressed much and it's been steadily
on the forefront in windham everyone
just wants answers and closure
especially since we have a local
election this coming tuesday
the voters are losing trust and it's
disheartening to say the least i can
speak for one team's local election
officials that we put our heart and soul
to make sure that each and every
election is run to the best of our
ability while following all the laws and
processes has always and continues to be
of the utmost importance this is exactly
why we take the oath of office
please consider voting in favor of this
amendment and please make sure to
include our local winter invoice in this
process
with that if it's okay with you madam
care
could i defer to the winter moderators
because they're they're also with me in
attendance here
um
that is a deviation from what i said i
was going to do to the rest of the
public but given um the fact that we're
doing this
electronically and ease of access and to
expedite banners uh we will um before we
do that does anybody have any questions
for ms botai am i pronouncing your name
right
it's bow tie
bow tie thank you representative o'brien
thank you madam chair and thank you for
joining us um ms bowtie
my question to you is were you at the
recount
uh
in your official capacity as a town
clerk and when you
if you were
did you see anything amiss
that concerned you
at that recall
oh
she's not david so
hear me
did you want to answer that question you
don't have to answer the question
jeremy i'm having problems with my um my
audio here
so my response was i wish i was
there at the recount that day but i was
by myself in the office i could not
attend personally however one of the
moderators that is sitting with me
did participate in that recount as well
all right thank you any other questions
for
this bow tie
i'm not seeing any um all right so
uh
the moderator who's sitting with you
would be who nicole
um peter griffin and betty dunn so i'm
gonna pass it to peter right now
okay so peter griffin
the moderator
we're going to try and give you some
accommodation from because you're from
wyndham but um peter is done
you have about four minutes
and we do have just so you know or at
least i do
and i believe that the committee does
because i would have only gotten this
from my email
is ms dunn i understand that you wrote a
letter
um
to
the secretary of to uh in regards to
this and you've been involved in this
for a while so
um welcome to peter griffin and then
we'll hear from this doug
thank you madam chair i appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you uh as
ms
the town clerk said i'm the town
moderator in windham here and a little
closer to the microphone you're coming
through a little muffled for us i don't
know what the speaker setup was is there
how is that now can you hear me
it is a little better thank you you're
welcome thank you madam chair yeah i've
been the moderator in windham at the end
of this term for 28 years
and we are really disturbed about what
has occurred and we want
resolution to this very quickly
i was part of the committee that the
selectmen assembled the other day we
spent over three hours
crafting a list of
bullet points which you had read earlier
in in the uh
this session
i can
recommend
finally that you please adopt the
selectmen's list of
bullet points as part of your bill
um i will now turn it over to betty dunn
who is my assistant moderator who was in
attendance at the uh
at the recount
thank you mr
griffin i will as well with you here um
peter and i serve on a board for many
years together um miss dunn welcome
the real point i've been listening to
the testimonials miss john i need you to
speak up
i've been listening to the testimony of
the
at this hearing
and i think one important point has to
come up and that is that at this point
we do not know which set of numbers is
correct
were the
numbers correct or were the recount
numbers correct
and if we find out that the windcam
numbers were correct
um then
the
machine is really pretty moved
and i would like to describe you a
little bit about what i observed that's
three pounds
namely that um
yes it appears
done i'm not trying to cut you off for
some reason as compared to mr griffin
your testimony is coming from very
uneven
um i'm looking at the people who are
attending my video are you also having
that experience
because i know sometimes when you're
just all on the video
zoom platform you get sound differently
than we do in the room but it's coming
through very unsteady so if you could
find that microphone and stay close that
would be great
is this better
you either okay
yeah
let's try this does this work
that's much better okay
don't hold don't move i don't know where
you are don't move
i won't move
i haven't moved
[Music]
we really can't hear you and i don't
want to have you go through what you
want to say and then have me say at the
end of it we didn't hear it
um
why don't
i
i don't know what to do
um okay
um
keep talking
i don't know
all right let's sign it on a different
environment
divide your phone
yeah
there is a notice that if you call in by
phone um
sometimes that works better i don't know
where you're at
if you want to try that with the zoom
notice there should have been a calling
notice and then maybe you can have
you can raise your hand and uh
maybe
apparently peter can
peter griffin can raise his hand but i
think i need you to call in or or
you know what it's done log off and log
try to log back in because sometimes
just breaking
one helps i'll go to the next person and
then i'll ask if you're on the line and
come back to you okay
okay
thank you of course that was very clear
all right
all right next signed up to uh speak on
this
is
uh
i have a
preschool
are you here rochelle
i'm going to call these names out and if
my vice chair can keep an eye out to see
if the hand goes up for them
uh representative gay has signed up to
speak on this bill representative gay
are you with us
yes
all right representative jay welcome to
this bill
thank you very much and i
i went through a whole day of hearings
the other day so i know how
important it is to put everything
together as quickly as possible i did
send
um an email and my concern is that
as important and critical as the
forensic study of the
scanning machines is
there is more to the investigation that
needs to be done
and so a couple of the things um that's
why i really
without even looking at the list of 11
points that the people of wyndham have
put out i would really suggest that that
be studied and adopted as absolutely as
much as possible i think it's number
of
2021 606 38
house
um i would like to make sure that in the
study
all the paper ballots are counted just
the number of ballots and make sure that
matches the number of ballots given out
which should be on you know that should
be on the checklists
um i think that the title of this bill
is incorrect it
specifically talks about the
representatives race
that is settled we already know who won
the important thing about this
investigation is not who needs to be
representing uh wyndham the important
thing affects all of us in the whole
state and that is
do does the process work
all the parts of the process work so let
the forensic experts do their thing but
don't stop with that
look at all the
the concerns that the people of windham
have and address those too so that means
the title shouldn't say it's just
investigating representatives uh
uh
what do you call it the races
uh i think that all the races in on that
were went through these four machines
everything on that ballot ought to be
run through the machines again
and hand counted
it's such a huge
game
that's the two minutes
okay thank you much
thank you that is wrapping up i guess um
i think i just saw a screenshot of
nicole
um are you there with miss dunn
yes
this is nice
yes indeed yeah so okay let's do this
again
thank you
so
i think what the point i want to make is
that there are two sets of numbers
and
at this point we don't know which number
is correct
there has been all of this talk about
the machines may be wrong
um and maybe windham made a mistake but
really we don't know which number is
correct we know that not only the
attorney general and the secretary of
state have had access to all the
documentation that we've provided but
that many of the people like mr k eyring
and mr murray have
and no one
has
uh found anything
of significance to my knowledge in any
of the paperwork hundreds and hundreds
of pages that we sent up including how
many ballots we received how many went
through the machine
how many were counted how many were
given out
i mean we can give you answers and
answers and answers and on the secretary
of state's recount you cannot look at
any of the documentation and know how
many ballots were counted they did not
count how many ballots they received
they did not count how many ballots they
were counting
there were stacks of ballots that were
sorted in the beginning and one of those
stacks was of
blank ballots in this
race
in other words no one voted for state
rep
those were screened we knew they were
all blank but those ballots were put
into the box
un put back sealed up
without being counted
for the ballots that had um
one or two or three votes or votes from
e
from both republican and
democrat candidates those were
tallied but those ballots were not
counted they were sealed up into the
into the
boxes
so you have no idea how many ballots
were counted during the state recount
and i and
so when i
hear people saying that
we must be looking at the machines and
the machines must be the cause of the
discrepancy
i don't understand when you cannot
do a cross-check on any of those numbers
and you can do a cross-check in many
different ways on the town's
count
why is all the emphasis on the machines
um
wrap up and of course as i've said we
will take a written testimony
okay
i'm happy to answer questions
all right well thank you does anybody
here in the committee room have
questions for miss dunn the captain
uh i have a question thank you for
joining us ms dunn were you at the
recount
and yes notice anything
interesting
significant anything that you considered
maybe possibly a miss
i did not see and at first i want to
state absolutely that i do not think
there was anything malevolent that went
on i
and no i did not see anything
that
i thought was a mistake i was distressed
immediately when i found out that they
were not counting
all of the ballots and that even at the
end once they found there was a
discrepancy they didn't
at that point count all the ballots that
were available
um and also
during this process i'm not going to go
into detail about how it happened but
during the process there were many many
different stacks of
ballots on each of the four tables that
where the recount was occurring
and at one point for example on my table
i became so concerned that there were so
many stacks of ballots that i stood up
and asked them to stop
and to
make sure that we were aware of which
piles were which
and
to consolidate some of the piles so that
they wouldn't and couldn't be an error
now i did not see a specific error but i
think that there's significant
um
risk of error in that process when there
were just these stacks of ballots
without any labels on them
thank you miss dunn representative pair
very sorry
yes um
how many people would you say were at
the
did you hear the question it was how
many people do you think were there at
the marine corps
um
rough guess i'd say 50.
and
it might not fall
at the original counting of the ballots
are the only counting to be fair yeah
yeah
um
well
we have four machines and we took and
the the tapes
came out of the four machines
and
there was also a hand count of eight
about 80 ballots
there were 10 06
ballots a pound
i'm hearing
not hearing you still i'm not quite sure
who's not doing
i'm sorry ms dunn we can hear you so
okay
so so the four um tapes that come out of
the machines were brought over to two
uh people who have done it for years for
us set up a spreadsheet
the information from the tapes was put
into that spreadsheet
and
i think the question was about how many
people were there at the end of the
night when the tapes and the ballots
were counted in windows
dozens 40
50.
there were observers there from both
parties um
there were a couple of dozen election
officials there were there were people
who were doing the hand counts
many people
all right thank you representative rowan
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
miss done for taking my question
uh
the proposal that we heard at the
beginning of this hearing uh
for a forensic audit
using doing using all four machines with
uh with some experts monitoring that
and then part of that process was
using a
another independent machine
to count all the ballots
independently of of your machines which
would then give a
an independent count
of the total number of ballots and the
results from those ballots
the fact that that's independent from
the machines that we currently have
would that satisfy
your uh
need for for a full recount
um sir that
i'm not clear
on what came out of the committee the
other day
that you've heard with the 11 points i
was not
part of that committee
but
um my personal opinion is i think that
if you did an
and a
a hand audit and i won't call it a
recount because it's not going to change
the outcome but if you did a hand audit
and it matched
what came out of windham on election
night
then we would know the machines were
fine
and
then all of the theories about somebody
messing with the machines would be taken
care of thank you any further questions
from is done
committee members in the room are
committed members attending online
representative living
thank you um uh miss sun
in the bill and you've referred a couple
times to four
sets of ballots is that because there
were four machines and they tried to
keep each machine's
ballot separately i'm just trying to
figure out why everybody's referring to
four
there were four machines however
i have wondered why that is is continued
because when the machines are emptied
out
the ballots were stored away
not in four separate boxes one for each
machine that has never been a
requirement or a suggestion and that was
not done
thank you thank you question thank you
further questions for ms dunn
representative homer
thank you uh thank you for uh answering
these questions
how long have you been an assistant
moderator and do you take the ongoing
training that they give me
i i have been an assistant moderator for
20 something years and i have also been
the school district moderator
for 23 years and yes i do take the
ongoing training and i read all of the
information from the secretary of state
and the various blogs and groups and um
yes i
i also by the way happened to be a
retired assistant attorney general who
in
although election law wasn't my uh main
thing on it at times i was sent out by
the attorney general to be one of the
inspectors i think i am pretty well
qualified
thank you mr
questions for mr representative
just a follow-up i didn't mean to imply
that you're not well qualified just
curious about yep
is that a question
no i'm sorry all right thank you further
questions
community members attending or online
i'm not seeing anything thank you miss
john i'm glad we got all the technical
issues worked out so we were able to
hear from you and see you today
um also signed up to speak on this bill
and i'm going to ask this person if
they're in attendance to raise their
hand i've got too many people attending
to what is stanley ceresi
it's stanley ceresey here
um
i'm not seeing
um maryland todd
are you here if you could i believe i
see you
yeah let us know what's good
very much
um
please todd you should be joining us in
just a minute and
can speak
can you hear me okay okay yes you're
with us thank you
um i was hoping i raised my hand to ask
mr steve scanlan a question and i was
hoping this wouldn't go into my one
minute time frame is that okay
what did you want we don't have
we just sort of so you know
and you know there are people who
certainly have more experience than i do
but if you have a question um as a
participant if you let us know what it
is we'll do our best to try and get it
answered while you're here online i
don't even know who's online at this
point okay i'll just try to get it all
done in two minutes because i have it um
first one okay so i raised my hand to mr
scalin's question and was looked over so
i'm hoping
um
this is not going to my content we
already talked about that sorry it's
insane to me anyone who logically can
look at the fact that each republican
gained 300 votes and state this anomaly
can be due to the hand count makes me
seriously question the agenda mr scalin
statistically speaking hand counts are
more accurate it worries me to hear
you state that we may never know what
happened in four months this is the only
time we've heard from the secretary of
state's office publicly anyways when i
started this journey i called the
secretary of state's office and was
assured that the machines are 25 years
old and what and also well assured that
they have no software during the same
conversation a few minutes later she
stated the machines were updated in
2010. i asked how how can you update
something that had has no software the
lady who i was speaking with put me on
hold and transferred me to bud fitch who
then stated it was actually firmware i
asked the secretary of state's office
multiple times
why they have not been more involved and
cannot answer the answer as to why as an
auditor who specializes in recreating
million dollar businesses transactions
using forensic accounting i do not feel
confident in the integrity or i am or
confident with the new hampshire
secretary of state or attorney general's
office i am a nashua and windham
resident in support of sb 43 and all the
amendments outlines with all due respect
if you don't support this bill i i fear
that new hampshire residents will fur
question further your dedication as
elected officials to the great news
people of new hampshire leading us to
cause a further divide between civilians
and our government it is time to unite
it is time for us to feel like you work
for we the people if this bill becomes
labeled tabled or rejected you give us
no choice but to question the future and
the freedom of our children i am asking
you to to not put us in this position we
shouldn't have to question our
children's future of freedom in america
by our reps not protecting our election
integrity i will assume many people have
here have children why would you not
want to ensure their freedom in the only
country if rand
if we're incorrectly by trusted
government would ensure exactly that
this is why election integrity matters
since when does the constitution protect
our government over we the people it's
like pulling teeth to rescan 10k votes
through a machine that produced the
largest voting discrepancy in new
hampshire history with all due respect
in my opinion this should this bill
should have been sent straight to the
house especially with the unanimous vote
in the senate as an auditor i can't help
but feel as though this is just another
process to delay us from getting the
truth this response this nonsense has to
stop finishing up
people will get the truth regarding the
gateway to our freedom with or without
the ridiculous processes we have to go
through our state's constitution gives
us this authority i don't think many
people understand the fact that if if
there is an issue within these machines
it literally means we are indeed not
free and i have no idea why more people
are not taking this more seriously we
need answers and we need them if you
could finish up that would be great
did i get it all out
are you reading something this time
you're welcome i know i'm done sorry
okay so you're welcome you're you're
welcome to email us
um what you were reading and
uh i suspect i i think deputy stalin is
us online here
and i understand you have some questions
and quite often at the end of hearings i
might recognize him to see if he has
anything he wants to address to clarify
for the committee
and so i expect to be doing that so
thank you very much for your testimony
today we also
also signed up to speak today and i need
him to raise his hand is alvin c is mr c
i s mr c i see you on my screen
um so i'm going to promote you to a
panelist and welcome you to talk uh this
afternoon the election launch meeting on
sb 43 and like the other members this
afternoon you have two minutes which is
wait you said three minutes on your
sign-in so mr c we're gonna try and come
in two thank you thank you
my name's alvin c thank you to the
committee and the committee chairman um
i am in full support of sb 43
and i agree with the proposed
um process that mr earing had
had suggested which would
satisfy the needs of affirming the
accuracy and public trust in the
accuvope machines
but we do need to
need an audit of the recount process to
be able to understand the approximately
300 vote discrepancy on the state rep
race
the testimony ms dunn
gave shows that there may be room for
improvement in the recount process
this audit is crucial to voter
confidence in the accu vote machines
used throughout the state of new
hampshire
most of our cities and towns use these
machines and the boaters in each of
these cities and towns want to know if
those machines can be
relied on for
accurate county and with that i thank
you for your time
well thank you for joining us this
morning does anybody have any questions
for mr c
i'm not seeing any here in the room
anybody online have any questions
thank you very much for joining us nice
to see you
um also signed up to speak this
afternoon is
kelly
business kelly with us
if you could raise your hand
i did see you earlier
i'm sure there are some people who
wanted to speak and connect because the
time and i i'm sorry that we were not
able to get everything done by the time
i approached
all right um moving on
uh dale age has signed up to speak on
this bill if dale ames is here could
you
raise your hand so i can find you on my
screen and we'd be
looking forward to you joining us
also signed up to speak is kelly potenza
kelly if you're here can you raise your
hand
bill smith
kelly i see you thank you very much for
raising your hand i'm sorry that i
didn't pick up right on it when you
up i think i just did
it's done back so we need to
move this done around and find his
potential again
help me with that
i'm here do you hear me
we can welcome
okay
the last time i did one of these it kind
of cut in and out so please stop me if
it cuts in and out um
gosh i had my testimony all lined up and
i'll um but now i'm actually going to
change it so
um i've lived in new hampshire all my
life except for like four years and
there's a lot of us that have known that
there's been some problems going on for
a long time in new hampshire but
when it comes to windham specifically
i just don't understand we are it's
march 5th
this all started november 16th
i just can't even imagine
why we are continuing to go through this
process it is so easy it's really easy
one person
there was a person that talked earlier
who can do forensic accounting could get
this done in one day run all the ballots
through each one of the four machines
literally do an audit of the ballots
count them all down
you can have a whole team there'll be
thousands of people that would be
volunteered to do this
so
what
mr scanlon said earlier is just so
concerning i mean it
some of the stuff does doesn't even make
any sense he says we might never know
what happened
i mean are you kidding me follow the 11
points in the amendment
pass through sb 43 follow the amendments
there's really no room for error in
there this really isn't rocket science
i i mean i just it's it's
bizarre that we are still in this place
um
i hope you realize we're all watching
this very closely this is this is so
beyond what's going on i mean we are
part of a group a lot of us
you got three petitions um sent to you
over the last two days and they were
hand delivered by me this morning and
those had um
combined over 1500 signatures of people
that have been working on this for a
long time we have
we have served the ag we have done
everything that we possibly we have made
phone calls
we have sent emails we've done
everything through the secretary of
state we have been ignored
and now only until we've got heroes like
ken and badaida and all these folks that
are that finally
you know we've got senate bill passes
24-0 and now it has to go to committee
and then it has to go to the house
what is this going to be by the time
this all gets done april i mean this was
november 16th that this all started so
i just hope you guys realize that what's
going on
we know we've been watching this all
along
the ag was served this doesn't even need
to happen legislatively he always had
the authority to get this done thank you
miss potenza um i appreciate your
comments but if you could wrap it up
because um you're over the two minutes
and we of course will submit written
testimony if you've delivered things
here
um today i i need to tell you we haven't
seen them so
wrap it up that would be great
yes so you did get the three petitions
correct because they were delivered to
concord today
from protect new hampshire and new
hampshire voter integrity
okay wonderful um so yeah i will send
you my written testimony um
i'd love to be able to answer questions
there's been a lot that's been going on
we've been working
many people hundreds of hours on this
and uh
do the right thing we're all watching
thank you does anybody have any
questions for miss potenza
anybody attending online or in person
i'm not seeing any so thank you for
being with us this afternoon
and thank you for the paperwork that was
delivered the petitions this morning
also signed up to speak on this bill
this afternoon is bill smith from
atkinson mr smith if you're here could
you raise your hand
um
i'm not seeing your hand so i'm going to
move on is james thompson here
mr thompson if you could raise your hand
representative love i know you were you
were here earlier you've been here for
pretty much the whole
thing um
and welcome to the election law
committee we've got a couple of minutes
to hear from you this afternoon thank
you for joining us
representative love you should be able
to unmute and be with us i believe
there how's that
now we can hear you
welcome okay great yeah good afternoon
good afternoon madam chair and committee
members uh my name is representative
david love i represent rockingham six
which is derry and i rise in support of
senate bill 43 and the amendment that
leaves no stone unturned in search for
the truth in the in the windham election
i believe it would be a travesty to look
at just the state rep race as it would
do nothing to to instill public
confidence in our elections
i uh i did attend that uh that meeting
on on monday night uh at the windham
select board meeting and i received a
copy of the uh the accu vote machine
tapes and the discrepancies at the top
of the ballot were disturbing to say the
least
begin to begin with uh
the uh
it was close to a third of the ballots
will run through machine number two
okay so uh in the presidential race uh
machine number one had uh 57.4 percent
for the president for president trump
number three had 56.9 percent and number
four had 57 percent
machine 2
the the machine that's uh that's really
got the troubles is uh is 42.2 that's a
14.9 percent average difference there
in the u.s senate race uh mr mesner
corki mester um number one his uh his
that machine was 54.1 number three was
52-2
and number four was 53.7
machine machine number two once again
40.1
an average difference of 13.2 percent
uh the u.s congress race uh wasn't
wasn't a whole lot different um
for steve negron uh machine number one
hit 55.1 machine number three 55.5
machine number four 57.3 and machine
number two here we go again for 43.6
that's an average difference of 12.3
percent
anybody knowing this should be appalled
you know election integrity is is
is at the very root of the tree of
liberty we need to restore public
confidence and you've heard a lot a lot
of no confidence votes in our elections
process today uh we need to prove
without any doubt just what happened who
was responsible and if there was a crime
committed the people and people a person
needs to be
the person people are personally
responsible needs to be prosecuted and
by the way
there was a vote counting machine in
derry that was very very different from
all the rest too uh i i don't know if uh
this this could be a statewide thing who
knows you know i don't like to be
pleased and speak to the bill and the
issues we're trying to address that
would be great
yes
well as far as speaking to the bill i
want an amendment that's going to cover
that whole ballot there's there's
anomalies on on on the whole ballot and
it it all needs to be addressed and
that's it for me any questions
thank you representative any
questions for representative cloud
representative sweeney thank you
thank you representative um and
potentially if you're not aware of my
rejection it's done for this question do
you know which machine since you seem to
be familiar with the machines of window
which machine will spend the absentee
ballots on election day
that that question was or thanks for
the question that uh that question was
uh was taken up at the at that meeting
and both the the moderator and the uh
the assistant moderator both said that
the absentee ballots went through all
the all the machines
thank you further questions from mr love
for representatives sorry representative
rowan
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question representative love i
had asked this question before but um
with the proposal that um
secretary of state said he supports uh
to have uh
the
ballots run through the four machines
and then have a separate
independent machine
not related to our machines count the
ballots completely again would that
satisfy your
concern
for comparison with the machines
mildly oh thanks for the question uh
it'd mildly satisfy mike's concerns i
think the whole ballot needs to be taken
taking a look at i mean if if say for
instance uh there was a crime committed
and these uh they do have uh memory
boards and stuff and if they run through
that memory board
um if they were programmed to uh to to
take uh you know to if that number two
machine was programmed to uh to hurt
republicans uh it very well could be uh
we need we need to look at every
possibility
thank you any further questions for
representative love
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for sticking with us through this
hearing representative love i know you
did all right welcome it's important
stuff thank you um also signed up to
speak on this bill is kim
kimond
kim if you were with us today could you
raise your hand
uh but
you're not right now and also
representative saudi
has signed up to speak on bill
representative saudi is one of the names
of the amendment that we received
earlier today representative saudi if
you're with us
uh brian masser has raised his hand but
has requested to speak
um and i just saw somebody raise their
hand i believe that's probably
hello can you hear me
is this lisa maysar yeah i'm brian's
wife
all right hey you have representative
baldwin
i i i have your hand raised
representative aldisaro and i have you
in two queries down to ask based on who
i had stand up and hands up sorry i'm
going in order representative love had
actually signed up
thank you thank you madam chair and
election committee for hearing my
testimony my name is lisa mazur i live
in goffstown new hampshire i have lived
in the u.s for 26 years here on a green
card from canada and just became a us
citizen this past january
the reason i became a citizen after all
these years is because i love america
with all my heart and i'm ready to start
using my voice with my vote i believe in
our country and our constitution but i'm
not gonna lie at this moment my faith
and belief in both of those things are
very shaken after what i've seen
happening in our country since november
it hit close to home when the
discrepancy was unveiled right here in
new hampshire this was the largest
discrepancy between machine and hand
count totals in the history of new
hampshire elections
because of this a forensic analysis of
the machines including cards and ballots
needs to be conducted the machines and
ballots are town property so the town of
windham
via its board of selectmen should
determine which firms does this forensic
analysis
i have never voted in my life and i'm
now terrified that my first vote in 2022
might be taken from me my confidence is
shaken in our voting system
rep representative scanlon you said that
we may never know what happened but we
sure as heck should
the accubo machines are owned by
dominion and dominion is a canadian
company these machines are banned from
being used in canada so maybe we should
take a cue from them
we have to get this right i don't
understand why you wouldn't want to get
this right as well it's been too long
since november
wmur and the union leader call this all
a conspiracy theory but for me it's a
search for truth regardless of party
lines
you have to do the right thing this new
citizen
and you can hear the passion in my voice
i'm a new citizen i care deeply about
this
needs to know that my voice is being
heard and that my first ever vote in my
life will be counted
thank you i'm in full support of this
bill and its amendments
for your testimony did you submit
written testimony also i did yes thank
you for that so committee members also
have that does anybody have any
questions for for miss mas or
representative barry yes ms matter um
first of all congratulations on being a
united states citizen welcome thank you
uh vlad glad to have you here um my
question is about your faith in our
elections would you say that things like
this where election abnormalities occur
cause you lose faith in the elections
and thus less likely to vote a hundred
percent i actually don't want to vote in
2022.
i'm so disgusted with what i'm seeing i
i can't even believe what i'm seeing
happening in this country i didn't sign
up for this when i signed up to be a
citizen i was so excited and now i feel
like it's all being taken away from me
i just it's it's unbelievable
thank you for that question
all right thank you very much for
joining us is andrew bridge here
i just he just raised his hand thank you
very much mr bridge go ahead you join us
and you have
two minutes
if you want you i think you're all set
and you're with us are you able to hear
me now
we are welcome great listen thank you
very much
um madam chairman i did send in my
testimony via email on wednesday march
3rd
under the under the heading of does my
vote count here in new hampshire
and like just the just the last speaker
um i am
not a new citizen by any means i've
always been a citizen here i'm 66 years
old i live in amherst new hampshire and
i'm very concerned
that we are losing our ability to
actually elect free representatives
freely elect
our representatives for a representative
government
i so much appreciate everyone there and
all of the work that all of you are
doing uh including mrs dunn um i i i
can't imagine the amount of work that's
that's necessary to put on an election
um but i think it's time for us all to
to stop necessarily patting each other
on the back and say there's still more
work to be done here there's some hard
work to be done
to restore confidence in our voting
system
i would simply like to say that that the
proposal that was made at the beginning
uh of this hearing uh with senator uh
with uh
mr garner and uh and ken eyring um i am
in fullest full support of um i think
everything needs to be completely
transparent and completely open
um i certainly would like to see all of
the ballots um
looked at and i do think that people
need to to remember that if there's a
forensic audit that will look at the
machines and the ballots
so um i think we might have both bases
covered there but that's all i'd like to
say please
help us we're asking for your help
in restoring integrity to our system and
i very much appreciate your time thank
you thank you mr bridge for being with
us this afternoon does anybody have any
questions for mr bridge people here in
the room or
committee members who are attending
electronically
i'm not seeing any so thank you very
much mr bridge and thank you for your
written testimony
um
and
us
to speak next is the ever patient
representative baldessaro
thank you madam chair uh i am a
co-sponsor of the bill and uh been on
your committee since this morning and
god bless your committee they've done a
great job but for the record
representative alba vasaro rockingham
county district five
uh which is londonderry um i also i
wanna i was a co-chair uh for the state
for the president and i received many
many phone calls questioning the
integrity of the vote
um i have the utmost respect for the uh
secretary of state bill gardner and
deputy um
scanlan i was at the wyndham count i got
there about halfway through
um all 50 people were not just there for
the um
the windham vote because there was two
or three different uh counts going on in
different rooms so there was people in
and out of there um as far as uh the
amendments that are going forward
i would support whatever ever we need to
do to correct this problem because
there's an integrity problem right now
with many people that are constantly
calling us on the uh wyndham not just
windham now i didn't even know about
derry's votes on the over our votes and
i know the londonderry machine broke one
of our machines broke at night the same
thing happened in nashua a machine broke
i don't know how many other cities or
towns that they had a problem
with a machine breaking because
londonderry didn't get their vote count
in until
405 or 4 10 in the morning
this is very important
for us to do
most people don't know we're finally
hopefully going to give the secretary of
state the authority to audit i don't
know why they never had it it should
have been done a long time ago but we're
not going to go behind whatever happened
in the past we're going to hopefully
move forward and correct this so i thank
you all
and hopefully we pass this and move it
forward so we can vote it in our next
session
thank you representative
for sticking with us for the day and
your co-sponsorship of the original bill
any questions for representative
alvasara
committee members or panelists
i'm not seeing any
so thank you very much for joining us
also signed up to speak today is michael
bryan
from
america votes and he indicated he needed
two minutes to speak which is just
perfect with our plan welcome this
afternoon
representative mr o'brien there isn't
representative o'brien but it's not me
[Music]
madam chair and members of the committee
my name is michael o'brien i
am here with operating strategies um and
uh justifying half of my client america
votes um very brief because it has been
a long day we do support um
this we feel it's very important to make
sure that we have answers um we also do
very much firmly agree with previous
speakers who said we should look into
the recount itself we don't know where
the error had occurred i also think it's
very important for committee members and
everyone listening
that there were lots of recounts done
and races that were large and small
and none of them produced issues like we
saw in windham so we should treat this
as an abnormality because it is
and we
need to find the answers but i don't
think it helps to start thinking this is
a larger problem when it seems pretty
confined that's all i really have to say
questions if anybody has any
thank you very much mr o'brien any
questions for mr o'brien from
committee members or
panelists
which would be committee members
attending online
i'm not seeing any so thank you very
much mr o'brien also signed up to speak
is
alex
alex tommy i believe
alex um
raise your hand
great i think you are muted and i'm here
thank you very much welcome
thank you for having me madam chair uh
thank you and your committee for the
patience the professionalism
and the
deliberate approach you've taken to this
problem it really speaks well for the
people we have elected on all parties
you've done very well
now that said i have uh submitted
written documents to you before
most important amongst those are reports
that indicate the number of problems
these machines have had not because they
weren't good machines in their day
but like the studebaker i had in college
they have seen their day and they have
as many problems as my studebaker did
that said
there is no bill that you can pass that
will fix the problem
that is not your jurisdiction you can
however
follow up on the senate's
uh good work and define the process by
which this process can be fixed
the proposal that mr ewing had
made with mr gardner is right on point
the forensic analysis of the machines
will answer a lot of questions not only
about the windham machines but also the
current state of our inventory so you
will have be able to solve the windham
problem or at least get answers to the
windham problem and give you an insight
into the machines and other problems
that may happen over the next couple of
years all that process
you will do and you will go a long way
to restoring the integrity or the belief
in the integrity of our voting process
here in new hampshire so i would
respectfully request that you pass the
bill with the amendments that mr erring
and mr cartner have offered thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
this afternoon and speaking with us
another one
does anybody have any questions
representatives
that comes with fruition that will
satisfy your uh
your need that we've
done what we can do to get to the bottom
of this well most definitely when they
do the forensic analysis of the machines
they'll be able to tell you
whether the machines are accurate or not
accurate uh and if there's a problem
they'll identify it if there's not a
problem
then they'll give you the direction to
go was it a problem made at windham was
it a problem at the secretary of state's
office a human problem but it will
definitely eliminate the question as to
whether or not it's a machine or a
programming issue and they will be able
to prove it by
running the ballots through a second
unrelated machine
it's pretty simple it's pretty basic
thank you thank you any further
questions
correctly
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for your testimony here this afternoon
thank you madam chair good luck
[Music]
i'll i'll take that at this point so
thank you uh also signed up to speak on
this bill is joan darby
from milford uh miss darby you should be
promoted and announced to speak
a lot of people on my screen right now
so i'm not quite sure where you are
somebody can help me out miss darby are
you there
miss darby i think if you unmute
yourself you will be with us
i don't know why i just go back to that
mrs darby
if you can unmute yourself you will be
with us
can you hear me now can you hear me now
we can welcome oh my goodness sorry
about that
all right um so i'm joan darjee the town
clerk in milford and i'm also um on the
executive board of the new hampshire
city and town clerks association and i'm
the co-chair of the legislative
committee along with dan healy and i'll
be really quick um
we are basically in support of this bill
um a couple of things that came up i
just want to address one concern
i agree with the forensic experts
looking at this but i do have to say
that i've just done a brief google
search on
some of these people that are being
called forensic experts and i don't
think that radio show hosts are should
be considered forensic experts nor
uh just retired army kernels um
i don't see anything in their bios that
that make them forensic experts harry
hursty happens to be
um he's probably got more of their i'm
familiar with him he's been in milford
he looked at our e-poll books um
but so i just want to caution
that we don't just use those names that
were handed out we actually find some
real forensic experts if you choose to
go that route um secondly i want to
agree with betty dunn on everything um
i think that
you know what you know we're getting all
kinds of calls as town clerks and um
the
uh without doing a hand re count audit
of the recount that was done i don't see
how going through the machines if the
machines come up with the same results
and again that doesn't match that hand
count
how is that going to tell us
that that the machines had a problem
most likely it's going to be found that
it is an error in the recount that
somebody just double counted stacks of
um 100 ballots because it's an odd
number it's 300 i mean it's not an i
it's usually you'd expect to be off by
some sort of an uneven number not a
total of 300. and then last um
the one thing i just want in in regards
to representative love i will tell you
that if he looked at milford's tapes we
had the exact same results absentee
ballots tended to be cast by democrats
and independents
and uh
that we had to put our absentees through
one machine because they were all folded
and you didn't want to mess up the other
machines you didn't want to create lines
because of social distancing so we
processed all our absentees through one
machine and our tapes that look exactly
like when windhams does obviously with
different numbers
and that's and that's all i have to say
and thank you for letting me letting me
speak all right great well thank you and
does anybody have any questions for
ms darby
online or
here in the room
i'm not seeing any so thank you very
much for being here this afternoon
and
also signed up to speak on this bill
this afternoon is mary till
mary are you still with us
is sarah
ibanez here please
sarah is from
bedford
i
might have also received something
written from sarah
i'm not seeing her hand
is
julie dicarlo with us please if you're
with us could you raise your hand
somebody just came on my screen
julie dicarlo with us
okay
um also signed up to to speak on this
bill is our own committee member
paul bergeron
there you go mr
representative bergeron
thank you madam chairman and i very much
appreciate you calling me at this point
because the testimony has been
fascinating um
i'll be very brief
you know my my main point is there's a
lot of reasons why election results
could be turned over during a recount
and many of those are due to human error
and that's already been addressed i
think both deputy scanlan and secretary
of state gardner said that there can be
a human error involved
in a memo that
the deputy sent out back on february
23rd he said he warned that jumping to
conclusions of what caused the disparity
at this point is mere speculation it
conject and conjecture
so my concern is is twofold first i want
to make sure that any kind of audit
that's conducted does more than look at
just the machines needs to also look at
all the paperwork the memory card
devices uh and the processes as well to
make sure that we can find out what
actually did happen and then give the
secretary of state an opportunity to
create the guidance that our moderators
and clerks and other communities need to
avoid similar situations from occurring
uh and one final uh very short story i
wanted to mention is several years ago
there was a state representative race in
hudson there were six open seats and the
election night returns showed two
democratic candidates tied for seventh
place
losing by 37 votes a recount changed the
finish
and the recount showed that all six
republicans lost votes as a result of
the recount and five of the six
democratic candidates gained votes
that recount happened in 1972
it was a while ago i was the person that
ended up winning the six seat by four
votes in the recount
and i would just add that the
mistakes occurred because of human error
there were no ballot counting devices in
service in 1972
so i would like to urge the committee to
keep in mind that any kind of audit
needs to include all other aspects of uh
election returns and counting and and so
on not just the
ballot counting devices themselves
thank you okay thank you representative
bergeron i i apologize i thought that
maybe you were speaking to
um something else because at some point
the committee is obviously going to need
to have an executive session on this and
talk about everything so um i hope
committee members don't feel that they
have to sign up for me to recognize them
and i didn't know if you wanted to talk
about something specific in your
amendment so
thank you that's fine i'm sure and i
my understanding is if we're sitting on
the committee we're asking questions and
that's why i signed up to provide
testimony
okay
thank you
i
to be honest representative bergeron i
don't know if i want to give the idea to
the other 18 members that are sitting on
the other side of this room and screen
for that but we'll see what the sign-ups
look like for next week and we'll see
what happens
yeah
i should tell you right now
i want to put the kabosh on that respect
all right
um is there anybody else here attending
electronically would like to speak on
this i have a couple people with their
hands out
albert todd i have with the hand up um
you're you should be joining us as a
panelist if anyone you
uh we welcome to hear from you and we're
allocating about two minutes so welcome
thank you madam chairman can you hear me
we can
awesome i wrote this uh quick testimony
and i'll email it in to you guys as well
um
i am a nashville and wyndham resident
and i am in support of the amended sb 43
bill i would like to point out that we
the people have already been waiting
four months for redress i encourage this
committee to establish a timeline before
leaving today and establish a date for
the amended sb 43 bill to be signed
i would like to continue by saying that
i am a united states navy veteran i say
i say this of course with pride but not
as a means to grandstand
however i will not digress from sharing
with you some of the conversations that
i've had with my fellow brothers and
sisters
some of us feel as though we have
sacrificed our time our liberties our
freedoms
our brothers and sisters to support and
defend the freedoms of politicians and
not the freedoms of our citizens
this is a major perversion of our
service to not only our great state
constitution but also our federal
constitution and we petition our state
government to correct this injustice
against us all
while we still have a chance i will end
this with a simple but powerful quote by
john adams and an explanation of my
choosing of this quote
you will never know how much it costs
the present generation to preserve your
freedom
i hope you will make a good use of it if
you do not i shall repent in heaven that
i ever took half the pains to reserve it
i mentioned the honorable john adams
quote because there was questions about
the president that this passing of this
bill may set
in my opinion the president
the president that this would set is the
president of our government uniting with
the citizens to honor to honor
the sacrifices our founding fathers made
for all of us by honoring the vote which
is at the heart and soul of both our
federal and state constitutions which
founded our great republican
thank you and god bless our great state
and our country
thank you mr todd for your testimony
does anybody have any questions for mr
toss representative homer brian thank
you ma'am chip
thank you mr todd for coming here and
sharing your thoughts and your opinions
and your experiences and uh your service
to our country
are you a windham voter or a national
voter
uh i would just bought property in
windham in 2020 and we're building we're
building in windham
hopefully so currently i'm a nationalist
naturally you just said that you were a
resident of nashua
so it just did create a little question
i i didn't know that it needed to be
followed up but thank you for
distinguishing that you're sort of in
the process of relocating thank you
any anybody else have a question for mr
todd
all right i'm not seeing any thanks for
joining us sorry also with
their hand up to speak on this bill and
it's been here for most if not all the
hearing is daniel healy mr healey you
have been promoted to a panelist and if
you've been you you should be able to
join us and we welcome to hearing from
you for a few minutes welcome back
hi
uh daniel hilly derry town clerk i'm
representing the new hampshire city and
town clerks association uh we are in
support of this bill as joan mentioned
uh with the wyndham amendments that
their committee discussed i am a little
concerned with representative love's
statement earlier
that the absentee ballots were spread
out through the machines that question
was asked at the the windham meeting on
monday night
in the selectmen that answered it stated
that the the absentee ballots primarily
went through machine one um gene mr
healey you're fading in and out that's
why i'm sort of leaning closer
okay
yeah representative love mentioned
earlier that the absentee ballots
were spread out through the machines
that question was posed to
the selectmen um at the wyndham meeting
on monday night and they did state that
the primarily the ballots the absentee
ballots went through machine one
the committee that that meeting is
available online the committee can watch
it back it was near the very end of the
meeting
we do have a similar machine tape
in derry
uh our machine tape
machine tape one in derry we have about
a thousand more democratic voters if you
look at the president race and it's
because that machine we used primarily
for absentee ballots i think if you look
throughout the state that would be a
trend uh putting all the ballots through
the absentee ballots through the one
machine
so i don't really believe that is an
issue that was strictly an absentee
ballot
machine and that's why the numbers
differ
and that was explained to representative
love already
um and that is it for my testimony uh
open to any questions thank you mr daley
any questions for mr haley
representative tarosian
thank you mr haley for taking the
question you may have said it when you
fade it out but uh you said it did come
up in the window meeting um
it came up
all of the most developed has developed
through machine tools they were spread
out
here you faded out uh they did state
that the majority of their ballots were
through the machine that had the i guess
the discrepancy that he referenced uh if
you watched the meeting it was near the
very end of the meeting it was one of
the last questions
but they did answer that they did say
that their absentee ballots primarily
went through that machine that was a
little different than the rest and that
is a common trend as the milford town
clerk stated and i do have that same
trend in my town and i'd be willing to
provide that that those those tapes to
you to show that um it was primarily
because of the absentee ballots
thank you thank you mr e lee any other
questions from mr healey
representative o'brien thank you ma'am
so
in derry all of the uh absentees went
through primarily one machine
and
possible that other communities choose
to spread out
that could happen not any specific but
that's what some communities do is that
what happens
that is correct
there's nothing that states all absentee
ballots have to go through one machine
or
if they're spread out so it's whatever
the community chooses i know most um if
they have multiple machines
instead of spreading them out they'll
pull one machine kind of to the side to
put all the absentee ballots through in
case they do jam or there's an issue
because absentee ballots are folded so
sometimes there's there's some issues
putting them through the machine
so they don't like to tie up all the
machines so they pick one
so you would see a trend
like that
we had way more voters that were
democrat choosing to vote by absentee i
just ran a report and it was almost a
thousand more than republican voters
thank you any further questions for mr
healey
thank you representative blanco with
that i'm sorry
um thank you madam chair um mr healy you
said something about there was uh
availability of something online to
watch was that would that be on the
town's website it is um available i
think it's windham tv uh they do
they do post their meetings so it should
be posted um it was about a three hour
meeting
okay uh so it'd be near the end i
believe is that when that question came
up
i'm not entirely familiar with
with their video system
i did check the meeting prior to that
was posted online so i'm assuming this
one will be if it's not already
okay thank
you further questions for mr healey
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
mr haley for joining us again and
helping us out
thank you
tina gilford it has her hand raised in
regards
to this issue
um this filter is from dairy and if you
at least you should
be with us welcome to stealth
can you hear me we can welcome great uh
thank you so much um madam chairwoman
and um committee
um since derry was mentioned quite a bit
um
i just wanted to speak to a couple of
different issues
we did run 4 500 of our
6 500 absentee ballots through one
machine
it is pretty much a very common practice
because you just tie up one machine
especially with
all the various social distancing and
trying to keep lines to a minimum
at the end of the day this
this is all about math um in the wyndham
race um voters were voting for four
they had approximately ten thousand
ballots
so there needed to be forty thousand
votes
um
a lot of them
may have been over voted um overvotes
are common especially in absentee
ballots where voters just put an x
through something
um
machines put that into overvote which is
like a blank
basically they make a candidate called
blank
if the voter leaves a race blank or if
they only vote for three or four people
they attribute three votes to those
people
one to a blank
um
at the end of the day it all has to
equal the correct number of votes when
you count them all um
and when the secretary of state does
their recounts they just count the valid
votes
um
to you know get to
you know what the totals are but when
you have an issue like this um
did they maybe
recount piles um of a hundred to get to
300 it's a possibility it could be human
error um
if you're going to audit this you have
to
audit it from start to finish
audit the machines
audit the hand count
run them through an independent machine
and and literally just look at it all
from start to finish and any other thing
is not going to answer voter concerns
my phone and my email has been exploding
with residents in derry
asking what are you going to do to make
sure the windham incident doesn't happen
in derry
considering we still don't know exactly
what happened in wyndham um it's really
hard to answer that question
um and i i just want to count voters
vote count the eligible voters count the
eligible votes
um be it with a machine or a hand count
or whatever it is
uh but you we do need to get these
questions answered
thank you
thank you for being with us this
afternoon during your testimony does
anybody have any questions for miss
guilford from the town of jerry
i'm not seeing any thank you for coming
and thank you for also talking about the
absentee ballots i know in boston the
clerk did a very similar thing they had
one machine for the absentee ballots
because of all the issues we've heard
about and the results were
different from a comparative standpoint
than the other machines yeah it's it's a
standard thing that moderators do simply
because you have to keep opening that
one ballot box take the ballots out
tamp them down because they're folded
you know someday maybe the legislature
will spring for telling us that we have
to use flat envelopes and then we won't
have that problem but that's a different
conversation
last summer you had one less fold this
way there you go if you got your back
all right is there anybody else
does anybody have any questions
i'm not seeing any so thank you is there
anybody else in attendance who wants to
speak who has not
already spoken on this matter
representative gay i can't remember
whether you've spoken on this or not so
much
be very quick i can be very quick uh one
of the
is that okay you're very quick or not
all right let's go
okay one of the uh things that needs to
be uh examined which in the forensic
they should is the question of why would
one one of the four
uh ballot boxes read so differently and
i'm just learning about some of in the
other states some of the things that
they found out in such suspect elections
was that there was a program in there
that actually put a percentage on
certain ballots so they boosted some
counts like 120
and then the opponent they set it to
read eighty percent so that
that's just one more possibility to
explain why one box would be so
another audit results because we can
start talking about the fact that some
states don't even have a procedure for
recounts and if you want to recount you
gotta go to court so
um thank you for your comments on on the
bill
um
did you have anything else you wanted to
add before we move on to dr strang
no i'm just very grateful that we have a
very safe recount method and i really
strongly doubt that we would ever have
mistakes like this on four or five races
uh
with the supervision that goes there so
i have a lot of confidence in in that
even though i'd like to see it redone in
this in this now in this surrey
investigation thank you
thank you representative gay um dr
strange we heard from you this morning
thank you for sticking with us for this
afternoon
um did you have something that you
wanted to add this afternoon to what the
committee's been hearing
yes madam sherman thank you i just
wanted to give the commit some
regarding the absentee ballots um mr
healey testified that
the absentee ballots were fed primarily
through machine one that is incorrect
windham had 3029 absentee ballots cast
but only 1 373 ballots were inserted
into machine 1 so it is statistically
impossible
for them to have put into machine 1.
they went into machine 2 primarily
because machine 2 had 3276
ballots the most of any machine and
was stated at monday's meeting was that
absentee ballots were spread out amongst
all of the machines but primarily went
into machine two
that's the machine where they where the
percentage for the presidential race and
the senatorial race were at great
variance to machines one three and four
so thank you for that clarification and
as we're finding out that variance was
consistent throughout the state with
machine counting ballots that had one
devoted to absentee ballots so thank you
for helping to clarify that
you're welcome
um is there
i don't see anybody else in attendance
with their hand up um i believe that
deputy scanlan is still with us there
were a couple of things said in regards
to your office and some questions that i
wanted to know whether you wanted to
we usually give the secretary of state's
office an opportunity to respond before
we close the public hearing deputy
stanley did you want to say anything in
closing here to the public hearing
section
yes
briefly thank you madam chair um
you know i understand that there are
strong emotions on this issue and those
emotions are justified
and
and you know we are very interested in
finding out what happened
to the same degree as everybody else
there are laws that we have to follow in
this process
even though i know people believe that
this process is moving slowly
there are things that are being done and
uh
but we only have so much authority and
if we were able to do things on our own
uh we wouldn't be here in this hearing
right now discussing uh this particular
issue
so that's number one um number two you
know i made a comment
um
about we may never know what happened
and i made that comment uh
in the context of
the human
uh a portion of this
you know the the machines are programmed
and i think that a forensic audit is
going to be able to go through those
machines
and they're going to be able to to
determine with
some exactness whether they're operating
properly or not there's no question
about that what i was referring to is if
it turns out that it is not the machine
that was a problem
and it was either at the recount where
there was an issue or whether it was at
in the town of wyndham where there was
an issue
if there is a human component in that we
may never know exactly what transpired
if if a stack of ballots got double
counted by somebody
um
yeah we we we're not going to know um
you know how that happened um
uh but you know i i i mean maybe there's
a possibility but but those are those
are uh situations where
you know we can locate where the issue
may have been but we may not know
exactly why
um
you know listening to uh representative
baldazzaro and some others you know i i
think there's a there's a low likelihood
that um
you know there might be some malicious
activity here you know if that is
determined then that will be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law um
but we have to go through this process
um you know i think we all share the
same goal uh we all want to make sure
that there's confidence and integrity in
our election process
um
it's really important i mean if we don't
have that then
um we're gonna we we will diminish as a
nation and that's in nobody's interest
so
um you know we're all on the same team
and uh we all might have different ideas
about
the best way to go about this i think
the proposal that is on the table that
was mentioned you know at the very
beginning of this hearing uh between
mr eyring and and secretary gardner is
is really a great place to start because
there's
you know there is uh some coming
together on this thing and and that's
important um
uh
so madam chair that's all i have to say
i mean if there are any additional
questions i would be happy to try and
answer them
representative cody thank you madam
chair um
deputy secretary it is true that we have
an obligation to try to find out whether
it's a machine problem or a human
problem isn't that correct
that's absolutely correct thank you
any other questions for
community scam like representatives
[Music]
i'm you're breaking up pretty badly so
can you hear me better
yes okay so assuming we passed this and
it becomes law from the from the date
that you know you have the authority if
you will to uh to go through this
potential agreement what would you
anticipate your expectation would be
that how long it would take to
come to a
final conclusion one way or the other
once uh once this bill were to be signed
into law we would act uh very quickly
and i would think that
within a matter of a couple weeks
you know we would make every effort to
have everything up and running
obviously um
you know part of the proposal is getting
some
some forest forensic experts in to
look at those devices you know we have
to contact them and and accommodate
their schedules but
the plan would be to to move along as
expeditiously as possible
representative
any other questions from any committee
members here in the room
uh at this time i'm going to close the
public hearing on sb 43 i want to thank
all the members of the public that have
attended all the members of the public
that have signed in
and i particularly want to thank my
committee members for what it's been a
long day and that i am going to ask your
indulgence to make it a little longer
um it is 3 15.
we're going to take a 10 minute break
so at 3 25 we're going to come back
we're going to
uh do the executive session that was
noticed from 12 o'clock i have heard in
history there have been some committees
that have been more than three hours
behind but
never me so i apologize
um and we will try to get the rest of
the work out of your schedule and
discuss the plans for next week so see
you in 10 minutes
[Music]
okay
um
this
so
and
you
uh
okay
we are waiting
all right um we are scheduled as a
committee to take up
um
votes on bills
excuse me 87 97 98 151 370 428 470 555
482 523 551 and 570
i will note that there is also another
committee still meeting here at the
state house so i think we can
get this done i do want to take this
opportunity to go through the schedule
for next week i know that we still have
people on the line who i suspect are
interested
in sb 43
um at a public hearing on sb 43 has
closed
um
we have scheduled next week on monday
public hearing on bills
and we have executive sessions scheduled
in the afternoon
um they have been
the remaining bills to be voted have
also been scheduled
um
throughout on monday and on
we have wednesday available also
i am not sure given the current status
that it would be possible to accept
everything on monday
um so my suspicion is at this point we
will be using the time on wednesday that
we have allocated for us and i believe
the start time for wednesday is 10
o'clock that's my recollection i have
not
looked at the
notices that came out as to the 10th
um
sb 43 we've heard about the underlying
bill and i just realized i never got
back to senator break was the original
producer of the bill
so my apologies into video space to
senator gray who i said i would go back
to at the end of the hearing
um do you have an amendment that's been
received in regards to
what i guess is the windham points that
the windham representatives
have
um submitted but i would
suggest that we're probably not going to
get to any executive session and i guess
i'll say it right now until wednesday on
this bill
so
we can have you know members
based on the testimony what we've got
from windows some consideration
and
we have asked as my recollection is for
the secretary and mr ellery to
actually provide a written summary of
what the points were that were indicated
that god had been proceeding
so hopefully
we will be getting that
and as a committee we will be able to
work together on an amendment
to and i think would probably just need
an amendment to
sb 43 but maybe we'll decide we don't
get to a solution that may come to that
we might be able to bring as the
committee to the house
for consideration
and for those people listening as to the
process
whatever we do here in committee we'll
have to go to the full house for a vote
if we change the bill in any manner from
the senate bill that we have in front of
us as suggested for example by windham
with its amendment it will have to go
back to the senate
the process after that if the bill is
signed off and agreed by both houses it
needs to be enrolled
will go to the leaders of the chambers
or sign off and then it will go to the
governor for signature
and so i know people are concerned about
the length of the process
but that is
the process that we are in right now
legislatively in the meantime i hope you
heard and understood
that the ballots have been secured and
have been retained and the ballot
counting devices and all of their
hardware and firmware has been secured
and none of that will be changed or
affected by the elections that are
occurring
so
do any committee members have any
questions
representative lane
we're having problems hearing you again
i don't know
you didn't have your headset on either
i'm sorry it's these headphones i
thought i turned them off but i guess i
didn't um
if am i understanding that we're going
to try and exec this
on monday but
but probably on wednesday i just given
how much testimony and how much
ambiguity on the amendments we have i i
guess i'm just trying to figure out i
wanted to let you know when the calendar
was set which had to be before this
hearing
i had optimistically hoped that we would
get through all bills on monday
but i have reserved wednesday the 10th
just in case i think it's much more
realistic given like
the hearing we had today
that we will be exacting bills to
include sb 43 on wednesday
thank you
i'm sorry for it it's i was being over
optimistic when i initially set the
founder and
i have been brought back to reality
today so there you go
any other questions and that's for the
benefit of people who are signed on who
might be interested in that bill i
i just don't
let's just have an agreement right now
it's not coming back to wednesday and
we'll deal with what other films the
committee can't afford
any other questions
all right
um
we are in executive session this is not
a public session we have noticed
particular bills
that we have previously had public
hearings on that this committee needs to
address
as to whether or not
the full house will receive them as
recommended
or ought to pass not recommended or i
further legislation in year two of this
session
the first bill that is noticed for
executive session is house bill 87
this is relative to the definition of
election
electioneering we had a public hearing
on this bill
on february 5th
we heard a number of people testify in
regards to this bill
and we received
a history and information from here from
pants farming our senior senior
committee researcher
on the issues into that bill
um before i asked for the role i thought
i looked to my clerk and say hey how are
you doing you've had a long day are you
ready to go
okay thank you representatives
um
at this time is there anyone that would
like to make a motion in regards to the
house
[Music]
second representative rowan seconds the
motion to retain 87.
is there any discussion by any committed
committee members on this
check
representative
yeah we heard
uh
feedback that the wording of the bill as
it is would create confusion and also
that the
rsa
sections that were referred to
for changes are probably not the
appropriate ones so i believe this bill
needs to be looked at much more closely
before it could uh be brought to the
board
thank you any further comments or
discussion on this by any county members
saying none i'm going to ask the clerk
going to ask the clerk to call the role
on hb 87 the motion before the committee
is to retain
um representative mcdonald yes
representative fruit home o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes online and yes
thank you and i can see you
representative
yes
representative barry yes
representative grohn yes representative
whaley yes clerk says yes
representative cody
no
representative cody can i see you for a
second
oh sure hold on a second
thank you
representative ward no
representative bergeron no
representative sandler
no
representative hamer
no representative lane
no
representative freitas
representative hamburg
no
representative your head
no okay straight in the chair
represent
griffin yes
and
will be 11 to 9.
11 to 9 hb
87 will be retained
the next bill noticed for both this
afternoon in our executive session
is
hp 97
this had a public hearing on january
this was one of the few bills we had in
regards to modifying the things of the
state
primary and associated
deadlines this particular proposal
change the date until
what
second tuesday of august
is there a motion on this bill
representative sweden yes madam chad
will be retained hb 97
is there a second a second
representative o'brien's second set
representative sweeney would you like to
speak to your bill yes thank you madam
chair uh as as you noted we have a
number of bills before our committee
that make adjustments to the calendar
for the state primary election uh while
other bills may be
coming out of this committee going to
the floor of the house retaining this
bill would give the committee the option
to continue to work on legislation going
forward into the future
to see if there's some other
factor
any further
discussion on hb97
yes thank you madam chairman um i'm
going to vote in support of the motion
to retain
um
as mentioned there were a number of
bills that came before the committee
dealing with moving the primary date
i asked the nashua city clerk to
pass some of those proposals by the
administrators in the school district
and frankly i was surprised that they
liked the august date because they felt
an early date in september interferes
with all the opening school year
activities like parent nights and open
houses and so on and similarly they were
concerned about the june date because
that's a period of time where you have a
lot of exam activities end of school
activities senior awards events field
days and of course exams
so um you know i i like the idea of uh
keeping house bill 97 alive and i will
vote to support uh that be retained
thank you for making those inquiries
does anybody else want to speak in
regards to hp 97 the mission on the
floor is to retain
i'm not seeing anybody so i'm going to
ask the third part
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative trump yes
representative quality yes clerk says
yes representative cody
yes
representative ward
senator bergeron yes
representative sandler
she's not a guest representative
he's muted yeah
yeah she unmuted
representative sandler if you don't mind
i just tried to is it are you hearing me
now
yeah
okay my answer was yes thank you thank
you
representative hamer
yes
representative lane
yes representative freitas
yes
yes representative your head
yeah
madam chair yes
comes 20 to 0.
hb97 will be retained
representative rowan has
uh
asked
as we have another executive session if
somebody wants to do something
to delay it i am more than open to it
representative
yes um
i had prepared an amendment to
move the date to the second the primary
date to the second week in june instead
of the first
and the filing date from the first week
in march to the second week in april
and uh it was brought up that that could
have
a conflict if we do not have the
redistricting plan done so
working on revising the amendment to
uh allow a trigger in there in case the
uh
redistricting is not completed by the
middle of march of 2022
all right so i i'm gonna expect you to
get that figured out for executive
session on monday afternoon
i will do my best
okay
thank you we're gonna continue that to
monday afternoon and the next bill that
is scheduled to be brought before her
vote today is hp 151
into changes in registration of certain
voters
after a primary election
uh representative matthew murray was the
final sponsor he prepared an amendment
to this bill
um
the amendment number was two zero two
one
zero four three five
does someone want to make a motion
in regards to the amendment for
hb 151
i'm chairman
representative
i'll make
oh they're almost done they're not on
the boat
okay
um i want to go to the grocery store but
it's jammed this up
and uh
[Music]
i am hoping that there is someone that
can speak to the amendment
that has been proposed by the
representative
because
my experience is that in committee
amendments are brought forward in
executive session by committee members
and that people then
the representative who's bringing it
forward then speaks to it
um i know that representative manueri
had
thought that he would present it but
i explained at the executive session i
generally deal with creating members
does anybody
have anything
to say in regards to the amendment
because he brought it forward
i'm not i'm not seeing anybody you know
well
you don't i'd be glad to withdraw my
ocean
make another potion
that's appropriate to make a motion
um
so i'm going to ask the clerk to call
the role on amending hp 151 with
the amendment number is 2 0 2 1 0
yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes
representative
representative barry yes
representative groom yes
representative quality yes
representative clerk says yes
representative cody
no
representative ward
representative
no
representative sandler
you need to have you
there you go
thank you okay uh no
uh representative kamer
no
representative lane
representative freitas
no
representative handler
representative your head
no
adam cheer chair
so it's 10 to 10. so the vote on the
amendment is 10 to 10 the vote does not
carry is there someone else who would
like to make a motion on this matter
madam chair i'd just like to clarify we
we are of the opinion that the amendment
while well intended does not really
meet
meet the issues of the bill thank you
thank you for clarifying that for me
all right
so
uh representative trojan do you have a
motion on hp 151 yes man i'm sure i make
a motion uh on house bill 151 in
expedient religiously
i'd like to speak to your bill
sure
yes thank you
so
well i'm sure this bill was intentional
i believe that um
ultimately the voter's responsibility
and he should retain that responsibility
to change
the act
if he or she decides to go from
undeclared to
a democrat party in a primary to vote or
undeclared
republican party
they make that decision to do that they
should make the decision to
to
switch back i don't think
we should put that
bonus on the back of
tom clark's be responsible i think
that's an individual responsibility
and if you're not sure
you're some testimony that some people
weren't sure
whether
whether they were registered undeclared
or a particular party you can always
contact your county clerk and find that
out
right away so i don't believe this
legislation is necessary and that's the
reason for the ideal motion
thank you does anybody else want to
speak
in regards to the motion on the floor
which is to itl hp 151
i'm not seeing any further discussions
so i'm going to ask the clerk to call
the role the motion on the floor is to
buy tl hb151
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative teresa yes representative
barry yes
representative brown
yes
representative
clerk says yes
representative cody
yes
representative ward yes
tony i i've been negligent can i just
see him for a minute unless
oh sure madam chair if you can stand
that i can't
yes
representative sandler
thank you
representative hamer
yes
representative lane
representative
fragis yes
jennifer hamlet
no
representative jr head
yes
madam chair yes
all right so it's 19 to 1.
19 to 1.
um is it permissible for this to go on
the consent calendar or should we put
this on a regular calendar and i've
asked representatives
that's fine with me to put on the
consent calendar i just thought more
work should be done on it but
that's fine
all right thank you
for that
um the next bill to me
we're gonna go on this afternoon by the
committee is hp 370 this is relative to
the election of the lectures of the
president and vice president of the
united states there was a public hearing
on this bill
on february 17th
uh is there a motion on this bill
thank you madam chair
make a motion on house bill 370 and
expedite the legislation
is there a second i'll second that
so
while there was some
parts of the bill i liked there were
some problems with it as it was written
and there was some discussion of a
possible amendment but
when i remember the
prime sponsor didn't um
couldn't
agree it wouldn't support that so
as it's drafted it's has problems
it's not ready for prime time
and that's the reason for the itil
motion
thank you does anybody else
want to speak in regards to hp370 the
motion on the floor is to
bring it to the house as an expedient to
legislation
i'm not seeing anything so i'm going to
ask
mcdonald's yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative trojan yes representative
barry yes
representative grohn yes
representative whaley yes yes
representative cody
yes
wherever he is
did i see representative cody
oh right madam chair as i said you can
stand that icon
this habit is fine for me to get into
it's near them
representative ward
yes
representative
jeff sandler
yes
representative hamer
my
my vote is um yes to itl
sorry my cable went out
with us now you're all set yes
representative lane
yes
representative freitas
representative hamlet yes
representative your head yes
madam chair yes
the ita motion on hb 370 the final
vote is 20 to 0
um
your injection
it will go on the percent number
hp 70 will go on a consent calendar
the next bill to be focused on today is
hb 428 this bill is relative to the
procedures for apportioning electoral
districts
this bill had a public hearing on
february
17th
and this is uh
a districting after a dust
consensus that occurs every 10 years
uh
hb 428 gives their motion on 428th
representative
madam chair i make a motion
to find house bill 428 and expediting
the legislation
is there a second i will second that
the
motion has been seconded by peter
hayward
representative
would you like to speak to your motion
certainly thank you
so
fortunately was a bill relative of the
procedures for a fortune electoral
districts and what it did is it required
the signal to since its information it
also
the way it was set up required
committees to set up a website
and for committees to have meetings in
every county
this would
prepare a certain cost for the state to
do
i don't think it's necessary
we're currently doing a lot of things
with zoom
so
that was problematic for me
the other thing is there's some
discussion it was a good idea because
during redistricting
one party
always uh
excuse me one
their favor looking at the election
redistricting committee
um
it's it's it's pretty close to i mean i
know it's
it's not completely even but it's eight
to seven members on the committee
so
i don't believe that um
we're gonna have a problem with that
and
this would simply
cost the state money for an unnecessary
uh requirement
that's it
is there any further discussion on hb
yes ma'am chair
cody
thank you i will oppose the motion of
itl i think there may be some problems
with this bill but i think it it got a
lot of strong support from several
people who communicated with me
and
there may be some issues that would
prevent and ought to pass but i
certainly don't think itl is the
appropriate disposition of it
thank you representative
i can say that i think he has some good
ideas in regards to process
and have to go forward
um
but i don't
think it's
necessary for it is it
this positive of what i suspect people
would want
so i appreciate representatives position
on this and
holds his closure representative to
roxanne refer to the
the commission that has been set up now
i believe again and both myself and
representative on
chair excuse me but there is something i
neglected to mention and that is that in
we did require the redistricting
committee to meet in every county in the
state and it is true under under present
circumstances that may not be necessary
but but it is not as though we haven't
ever done it before thank you
thank
you further discussion on hb 428
yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward josh
representative mooney yes
representative teresa yes representative
barry yes
representative brown
yes
representative kweli yes
representative
clerk yes
representative cody no
representative ward no
representative bergeron
no
representative sandler
neither hamer
no
representative lane
representative freitas
no
okay
cody if you can just appear on screen
for a brief second thank you
representative lane representative cody
thank you
and representative freitas are you with
us where are you
oh am i here not there
i need you
there you are you're on your video we
need to add it's one of just one of
those rules because
who knows
that somebody's outside your door dying
to vote on these bills
all right thank you for
helping me comply with the rules because
i need all the help i can perform
all right so representative freitas
your position
no
thank you representative hamlet no
representative your head
no
madam chair
yes
okay so 11 to nine
hb 428 will be reported to the house
as
um expedient to legislate will there be
a minority report
i haven't had an opportunity to discuss
that i'm chair i will let you know
before the end of the day how about that
you know next week
all right the next build schedule to be
going on today is hb 470 hp 470. it's
relative to the designation of
office on ballots
and this bill would require the
secretary of state to highlight the
maximum number of votes a voter may cast
for an office it had a public hearing on
february 17th
um does is there a motion on hb 470
representative hayward
i'm chairman igl
representative hayward moves in
expedient to legislate is there a second
has been that it's been seconded by
representative o'brien is there any
yes i
think home
anybody want to explain the itl on this
vote
this was a bill just for anybody who
might be representing who might be
listening that required a
highlight or a watermark or some sort of
undefined
uh notation on the ballot to highlight
the number of uh votes that should occur
and it was pointed out during the public
hearing that the ballot itself actually
has expressions on it
and there was
i think all i i was going to be sort of
perplexed as to how we
madam chair i can talk to the itl motion
as well i'll be voting to itl although i
can appreciate the sponsor uh taking a
measure to highlight an area that could
be perceived as confusing there really
didn't seem to be an overwhelming need
for that particular change
and once we get into ballot design
really the options are endless so for
that reason i will be voting itl
thank you anyone else on the itl motion
for 470
i will ask the court to call the role
for the discussion
representative mcdonald
yes
representative
o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes
representative trojan yes
representative perry yes
representative
yes
representative kweily yes
representative cody yes
let me see representative cody
oops wait a minute
thank you
representative ward
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes
representative hamer
representative gamer's on oh
that's
yes did everybody freeze or was it just
me
oh sorry represent lane
i didn't think that you did but
oh okay
uh
is for itl correct
yeah yes yes
representative freitas
yes
representative
representative your head
yes
madam cheer yes
20 to 0.
hb 470 will be recorded to the house as
an expedient to legislate with
synonymous voter 2-0 without injection
it will go up
madam chair could i just say that it's a
pleasure after a period of some years to
hear representative mooney speak to a
motion again
thank you
the next
bill that we have before us this
afternoon
is house bill 555 hb 555 as far as
relative to prisoners voting rights
this bill would amend the absentee voter
application form and absentee voter
affidavits to make clear that certain
persons confined to penal institutions
may vote by the
ballot
this is actually somewhat similar to a
bill that i think is the same as a bill
that passed last year the public hearing
on this was on february 17th
is there a motion on this bill
yes i'd like i'd like to ride i move out
to pass on this bill
is there a second
representative
second state representative
would you like to speak to your motion
yes i would thank you this is an
interesting bill because there's
bipartisan support
and it's uh
the same bill that we we had last year
that you know fizzled out because of
coven and all of that
this establishes no new voting rights
for people who are in prison
what this does is clarify that people
who are in jail who have not been
convicted of a felony people who are
awaiting
a conviction or
a trial
hopefully not a conviction but they
they have the right to vote
if they're not in their own community
and that sometimes happens and right now
the absentee ballot request form asks
them about
being in their own community or outside
of their own community if they're i'm
sorry if they're in their own community
they are in their own community but in
jail
so there was some confusion and this
clarifies it
and just to reiterate this establishes
no new voting rights in the state of new
hampshire for
uh
criminals
because some of these people have not
been convicted yet
thank you is there any further
discussion on this representative barry
oh yes don't share with us
i'm sorry
i said
um
this is it i believe this is an
important bill um
a fellow representative of the
manchester broadcast forward and he
makes the point valley street is in
manchester it's the state's largest city
it actually sits just outside of my
district and it is possible for someone
to be arrested in the city of manchester
and held the city of manchester who is
has not actually committed a crime that
does not happen often but sometimes
people are arrested falsely so we need
to give them an outlet to exercise their
right to vote and this is a common sense
bill that doesn't create any new rights
but clarifies what could be seen as a
loophole that inhibits someone from
voting and i think it's common sense
thank you representative does anybody
else wish to speak to the bill
not seeing anybody so i'm going to ask
the clerk to call the roll on house bill
5-5-5 the motion on the floor is off to
the house
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative
yes
representative barry yes
representative brown
yes
representative kweily yes
representative cody
yes
can you see me madam chair we can't
thank you thank you
representative ward
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes
representative hamer
representative lane
yes
representative freitas
representative hamlet
yes
representative your head
out of chair yes
sparrow
goes over to the house
as it's recommended
to pass without
so this will appear on the consent
calendar
the next bill scheduled to be addressed
this afternoon by the committee is hp
482 this is relative to the use of
campaign
personal use expenditures
um this is what's a slight redraft of
the build that was trying to make its
way through the house last year
and
we heard it the public hearing was on
february 5th is there a motion on age
24.
i'm out of chair i ask that we retain
this
representative wells means that we
retain
so
um
we're going to retain this bill there is
potentially some merit to
passing this
i think we need to do a little more
study on it before we uh
it's ready to be
potentially passed
is there any further discussion on the
bill or the motion that's in front of
the floor it is to retain this
and i will say my recollection is this
bill got a fair amount of discussion and
prior years
the the crime sponsor did do some
modification and detailing of it as
compared to how
um the statute exists currently
um and in fairness to the sponsor and
the committee the reality is this has
been a very different year for public
hearings that going forward and
um
it is
the secretary of state's office
acknowledges that this is a grey area
um and i just think that before we
toured in this it would be
creating less confusion it's always a
good thing so that's why i applied for
the supporting motion to retain
any further discussion
i'm going to ask her to call the vote
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
mooney
yes
oops
representative barry yes
representative brown yes representative
whaley yes
yes
representative cody yes
oh he looks awful representative ward
yes
senator bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes
hamer
representative lane
yes
representative freitas
representative hamlet yes
representative your head yes
let me just uh manage here yes
count is 20 to 0.
hb 482 will be detained
hb 523 is the next bill that the
committee is scheduled to address today
uh hb 5 23 had a public hearing on
february 12th this is a bill requiring a
person to register to vote without any
identification to house his server
before his or
her registration to vote is
complete is there a motion on hb 523
representative barry yes madam chairman
i knew that hp 523 be ought to pass
is there a second a second madam chair
representative
members of the committee i've spoken
at length about people's faith in our
elections
i've spoken at length about the process
in which someone may same day register
in the state of new hampshire i want to
go over that real briefly because this
bill pertains to that in the state of
new hampshire you may walk into the
ballot box with you may walk into
the uh location
not being a registered voter walk up to
the same day registration booth with no
id and no proof of residency and you may
register to vote but one of the things
that happens when you don't produce a
photo id is they ask to have your photo
taken it's a measure to try to ensure
some valid integrity however you are
allowed to cite a religious exemption to
not have your photo taken
you then sign the qualified voter after
davis which is another conversation for
another day
the notion that somebody will be able to
go to the polling location
and not have their photo taken
is really far out there in modern day
society it's nearly impossible to go
outside without being on camera
my car has a backup camera and my camera
right now on my laptop my cell phone has
a camera it's almost impossible
so this exemption is rarely used
and because but it does however create a
extreme amount of distress in our
electoral process and by removing it
we won't be inhibiting anyone's genuine
access to the ballot box
what we will do is in a very small way
restore some faith in our election and i
would think that after today's testimony
where nearly 400 people signed up to
express in one way or the other they
have distrust our elections that we
would take positive momentum towards
that
does anybody else want to speak
i'm yes ma'am chair i would like to
speak against the motion
thank you representative
the state of new hampshire got along
very well for many many many decades
without any such requirement and i have
yet to figure out what happened about 14
years ago where it suddenly became more
of an issue than it had been for the
previous
several decades thank you thank you
representative cody does anybody else
wish to speak to the motion on the floor
i'm going to ask her to call the world
before the
o'brien yes
representative sweeney
yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes
representative trojan yes
representative barry
yes
representative crone
representative kweily
yes
clark says yes
representative cody no
representative ward no
representative bergeron
no
representative sandler
no representative
no
representative lane
hello
representative freitas
representative freitas you need to have
you up
here you go
and your hope is
i said no
thank you
okay
representative gambler no
and representative head no
out of chair
yes
11 to 9.
hd 523 will go on the calendar as ought
to pass the committee recommendations
one
hp551 it's relevant to the statewide
voter database this bill is required
that that
centralized order registration database
be made publicly available in electronic
format free of charge
with exceptions as allowed by statute we
had a public hearing on this bill
on
february 17th
um is there a motion on this bill i'm
sure i will retain
yes
a good concept and i support the
transparency that it attempts to
to
get however
we continue to work on it because
certainly some privacy concerns here
we also
should amend
the
bill so we can be more precise
exactly what data elements
thank you representative
is there anybody else who wants to speak
to the middle and watch it on the floor
which is to retain hb
551.
the motion is
yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes
representative trojan yep yes
representative perry yes
representative brown yes
representative kweli yes
clark says yes
representative cody yes
representative ward
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes
thank you representative hamlet yes
and represent your head
yes
madam chair yes
zero
hp 551 will be changed by the
committee the last bill that is
scheduled to be addressed by this
vote today is hp 570 that is permitting
certain political organizations to
appear on a general election ballot as a
minor party after holding
a nominated convention the public
hearing on hb 570 was on february
17th is there a motion on this bill
representative
thank you madam chairman i move that the
committee finds
hb570 in expedience legends is there a
second
second representative
representative would you like to speak
to your motion yes i would thank you
chairman
this bill as i see it has three major
provisions relating to political
organizations first of all it
adds a criteria of receiving at least
four percent of the votes
for the office of president united
states in order to be designated apart
secondly would change up little
political organizations candidates added
to the ballot and state elections
by allowing the substitution of a five
dollar filing fee
for each name by which they fall short
of the current requirement
of three percent of the total votes cast
in the previous state general election
uh the third significant provision as i
see it had a division
allowing a political
organization which did not win
more than four percent of the vote in
the statewide race to add its candidates
to the ballot by holding a nominating
convention and submitting its list of
candidates for general election within
three days of the primary election for
that general election
by the new hampshire law provides ample
opportunity for all political
organizations to place the candidates on
state ballots provided
they've shown even a modest amount of
support from the voters either through
past election results
or by submitting a sufficient number of
nominating from registered voters
thank you
thank you representative
is there any further discussion
on the motion before the board
yes representative futon o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes
representative
representative barry yes
representative crone yes representative
whaley yes
clark says yes representative cody yes
representative ward yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes
representative hamer
representative lane yes
representative freitas
yes
representative hamlet
yes representative your head
yes
madam chair yes
570 will go to the house
as recommended and expedient to
legislate it is 20-0 so without
objection it will go on the consent
council
i want to thank everybody here for your
indulgence and sticking with this today
with a very long day i apologize
here at the beginning of it
um
madam chair i do have an important
announcement for those of you who um are
attending in person
i think we've consistently met in 306
308 up until
um now
on monday you're scheduled to meet in 2
10 to 11.
all right well that should confuse us
for at least
thank you guys
hopefully somebody will leave betrayal
from this room
the front of the building